this is Jocko podcast number 394 with
Carrie Helton and me Jocko willink good
evening Carrie good evening
self-discipline the virtue of temperance
is the ability to keep your ass in line
the ability to work hard to say no to
practice good habits and set boundaries
to train and to prepare to ignore
Temptations and provocations
keep your emotions in check to endure
painful difficulties
self-discipline is giving you everything
you have and knowing what to hold back
is there some contradiction in this no
only balance some things we resist some
things we pursue in all things we
proceed with moderation intentionally
reasonably without being consumed or
carried away
Temperance is not deprivation but
command of oneself physically mentally
spiritually demanding the best for
oneself and of oneself even when no one
is looking even when allowed less
it takes courage to live this way not
just because it's hard but because it
sets you apart
discipline then is both predictive and
deterministic it makes it more likely
you'll be successful and ensures success
or failure that whatever happens
you are great
the converse is also true a lack of
discipline puts you in danger
it also colors who and what you are
and right there is a little excerpt from
a book called discipline is Destiny
I feel like I have to say it that way
the power of self-control written by a
gentleman by the name of Ryan holiday
Ryan holiday is a prolific author and I
don't use that term lightly he's a
podcaster a blogger a marketer a
bookstore owner an entrepreneur and a
modern day follower of stoicism
and it's a pleasure to have Ryan here
with us tonight to share his experiences
and Lessons Learned along the way Ryan
thank you for joining us yeah thanks for
having me it's been an interesting ride
for you yeah yes as I kind of pulled the
thread on your life and what you've done
it's it's an interesting ride to say the
least you know that was actually uh
advice someone gave me I wanted to be a
writer and they said okay writers live
interesting lives
the point being you can go train you can
go to the Iowa's writer's workshop and
get really good at putting the words in
the right order
or you can go do stuff and read about
stuff and experience stuff and then
you know write about that and and you
don't have to be as good yeah no I would
definitely say I guess I'm a living
proof of just go out and do some cool
stuff and then write about it you
probably do okay yeah I would definitely
recommend that course of action rather
than going to a long schooling look and
I went to school I was an English major
did I learn stuff yes I absolutely did
but I would I would much more recommend
going out and getting after it go out
and have Adventures get into trouble
cause issues cause Mayhem Let There Be
Mayhem in the world around you and he'll
have some exciting stuff to write about
yeah just yeah see people [__] up [__]
up yourself just just learn something
about the human experience that can then
like color the work that you're doing
yeah
um because if you don't yeah you have to
be way better it's like it's like with
music like you can be the most
technically brilliant person or you can
have some sort of emotional
experience that you are communicating
and and I think all the best music is
that yeah for sure that's a whole thing
for me uh you know I always give the
example that you can go to Guitar Center
yeah anywhere in the country and put up
a sign that says hey I'm looking for a
guitarist that can play
all of Led Zeppelin Black Sabbath and
Rush which is the most complex music
there is Rush and and you'll get 20
applicants that can legitimately do it
and they all have jobs as you know
waiters and construction workers and
then there's one kid that has this
streak of Chaos in his brain and what
he's been through in his life and he's
got some emotional connection with the
world or disconnecting with the world
and it comes out and there you go you're
like oh Jack White how you doing I mean
inve Malmsteen is a brilliant guitar
player but like I don't know any of his
songs uh I mean I've seen him live it
was pretty cool but again I don't know
any of the songs and there's a there's a
balance right there's a spectrum and you
can so you can be technically brilliant
you can just have a lot to say ideally
you want you know temp the funny thing
is temperance the stoic virtue is also
rendered as sort of moderation or
balance you want both it's right in the
middle but you you need the combination
of the two I'm gonna try not to do this
all day but I also wrote a book called
The dichotomy of leadership and it's all
about the balances of everything that
you do in life and if you're hey the
ego's bad but if you have no ego then
you're just sitting around you know
watching Netflix and doing nothing and
if you let your ego get out of control
obviously we know that's a problem too
so yeah the the idea of balance 100 and
that does include
being a rock and roll guitarist although
you could take the sex pistols and you
could probably say they were as about as
raw I mean Sid Vicious on base he
basically learned how to play the bass
you know three shows before or whatever
and got up there and just hammered all
that thing so
they brought it yeah yeah and and just
like there's brilliant technical
guitarist too right so so but I think
the best it's the com you know the gold
you know the golden mean Aristotle's
golden mean no so Aristotle's golden
mean is basically this argument right
he's saying that okay um he actually
says courage so the the four virtues
courage discipline Justice wisdom he's
saying that courage actually illustrates
the the virtue of discipline because
courage is not on one end of the
spectrum courage is in the middle of the
spectrum there's recklessness and then
cowardice on the ends of the spectrum
and The Virtue the thing you want to be
is actually in the middle and pretty
much everything in life is like that
it's in it's in the middle because
there's always an extreme version that's
too much
most people don't have the too much
problem they're not too good at their
thing most people are not good enough at
their thing or don't have enough of the
thing but
actually you want that middle ground so
even 2000 years ago they're like more
than two thousand years they're like hey
look it's a balance it's a balance yeah
for sure all right so let's go let's go
through where how you ended up here
today how did you get here today uh
where were you born Sacramento
California
exacto yes Sac Town yes and what did
your parents do my dad was a police
detective and then he worked in the EOD
unit and then my mom was a school
principal a vice principal
so very sort of blue-collar Regular
People jobs as pretty much everyone in
Sacramento is I think people think
California is all this and it's it's
much more sacral it's much more
Sacramento than the other place yeah
Sacramento or sorry California is first
of all it's a bunch of Agriculture
massive agriculture you drive outside of
the big cities and you're just going to
run into Fields yeah and so yeah and
it's huge blue collar
um State and there's just a few cities
that
are not very blue collar at all yes I
don't know what they are yeah uh so
you're growing up you're was your dad in
the police Force's whole his whole
career that was his correct yeah and
your mom same thing she teaches her
whole life and then became a principal
at some point yeah
and what were what were they like
growing up they were like regular people
you know just regular people did you did
you relate to your mom or dad from a
perspective of like hey my dad's a cop
I'm gonna be a cop or my mom's a teacher
Vince principal I'm gonna go in that
direction no I would I would say we were
not on the same Vibe like I I've and I I
got the sense that they were like sort
of where did this kid come from also you
know it had the same sense with my
parents
um yeah it might have been the exact
opposite uh yeah like I would have loved
an English teacher you know what like
that that's who I was like I was into
that stuff and also I think
I think um I've said this before but
hold on you say you were into the so my
mom we were talking before hit record
that my mom was an English teacher my
dad was a history teacher so you just
you just said yeah well it's weird too
because people always like oh that's
weird that's why that's where you are
the way you are and blah blah blah but I
was my parents were looking at me like
where did this child come from yeah why
is he act like this where did where
where is this genetic
um of thing fell apart some at some
point in our lives
um but you you just said you were into
it so you're talking you're in high
school and you are into literature yes
books uh ideas like I I wanted I was
like so excited to go to college because
I was like that's gonna be it you know
then you get to college and it's like
here's a group project you know it's not
what you think it is but what kind of
music were you into heavy metal so that
also they were like who is this kid you
know what's going on why does he spend
so much time in his on his computer in
his room why is it growing his hair how
did you get into heavy metal
uh uh what was your gateway band
so I got into Iron Maiden I I was trying
to illegally download a Metallica album
and I downloaded an Iron Maiden album
and I was like what is this [__] you
know this is like I love Metallica too
but Iron Maiden is like a different
level and I think for me being a history
person you're like wait these songs are
about things you know what I mean like
like and then I would go look up what
those things were you know so I just
fell totally down this Rabbit Hole of of
heavy metal that's right that's rad and
so you're into heavy metal you're
reading books dude you're you're
freaking weird at this point yes you did
not goth or anything but I was weird
okay yeah what were your friends we did
you have friends that you're hanging out
with yeah I Ran So my parents like
having a dad as a cops like you got to
play sports and I remember I went we
moved when I was in high school and so I
started this new high school and he's
like I want you to play football and so
I uh you know you go and everyone's in
this theater of course all these kids
have played football their whole lives
I'm not and then the coaches starts like
screaming at everyone and I was just
like this is not me this is not what I
want and so I ran cross country in track
before so I was like a running a runner
a very skinny Runner kid who was always
getting into trouble were you any good I
was pretty good but I was I was uh I was
afraid of actually trying I realized in
retrospect like I was pretty good and I
would do what I could do on my natural
talent but the idea of really trying
clearly there was some part of me that
was reluctant to do that
because the same reason why a lot of
people don't try is that if you fail
then it's on you so I was I I just
messed around like in retrospect cross
country was insane I don't know how it
is anymore but they'd be like you don't
get to cross-country practice and then
they would tell a bunch of 14 year old
boys to go on a 50-minute run and come
back you know and so we would go to my
friend's house and play video games
steal stuff and then throw it off
Bridges you know we would just do we can
just do whatever we wanted you know so I
was I was that kind of kid yeah there's
a whole there's a whole subculture I
guess of just stealing stuff and
throwing it off of bridges for 14 year
old boys I mean yeah of course that's
the best it's like do you know if you
throw a computer monitor off a bridge it
implodes you know just like you just
find stuff out that's you know those
little scooters the bird scooters and a
bunch well I don't know what it was like
I don't know you live in you live in
Texas right yeah I don't know do they
have them down there yes unfortunately
when they originally brought them here
to San Diego just every time they would
put them out people would just destroy
them they would just throw them off of
bridges throw them off of cliffs just
destroy them and I remember reading some
article about it and and I guess the
first one of the first places they did
it was in Holland or something
and I said man the Dutch people seem
super nice and chill and they were like
oh great electrical scooters that we can
ride around and Americans are like cool
[__] we can break the 14 year olds in
America were like no we're not having
this so that's what happened I I
definitely get the impulse too not just
because I like throwing stuff off
Bridges but like in Austin there's this
Trail Around Town Lake you know the
really cool Trail which is awesome it's
like it's amazing one of the best
running trails in the country and people
they're not allowed on this Trail but
not only will people take them on the
trip then they just park them in the
middle of the trail so every time I see
them I want to throw them off something
I I've I've conquered that impulse but
uh everyone so I'll see one in the water
and I'll go I get it you'll give a nod
of them yes good job to the 14 year olds
out there We Salute You Yes exactly so
are you getting good grades I was okay
uh again I think they're I when I look
at my high school experience I see it
defined by you know like 70 of potential
like when I hear kids who went to like
Harvard or the Naval Academy I'm always
like blown away because like they got
serious and good like way before I was
I cared yeah you know what I mean or
their parents got serious with them sure
sure with some short term like if you
get A's yes and then they program them
correctly or they're just into it which
is also true yes definitely but but just
like to be in any way close to like
a high level of performance at 16. yeah
just is is incomprehensible yeah you you
were not there no I was not there I was
well first of all I just knew I was
going to the military so everything else
just seemed like a big joke to me
because I'm an idiot
why would I have to do school work this
doesn't make any sense I'm going to the
military yeah uh so did you have some
kind of a plan uh some kind of a vision
of what you're gonna do uh I knew I
wanted to in Sacramento I don't think I
met a single person who did not have a
job and I knew I wanted to be a person
that did not have a job like not that I
didn't want to work but I didn't want to
like I didn't want to have I wanted to
be a person who did like the stuff that
they wanted to do and so there I had
this vague sense that Southern
California was a place where stuff like
that happened you know what I mean like
movies or music or writing or whatever
so so job to you meant like nine to five
job you're working for the man yes you
have a you have a salary you are not in
control of your life and you didn't like
that idea I didn't like that idea I
didn't know exactly what I wanted to do
and I wasn't I wasn't even sure
it was until I went to college I went to
Riverside and like you meet College
professors and they've written books and
papers and their works but you're like
oh this is like people do like I
remember we had this seminar uh my
before I started my freshman year it was
like a summer thing that I did and there
was this novel street name is Susan
Strait I've gotten to know since but she
like we all had to read this professor's
novel that had won like some big prize
and it was like oh this is just like a
regular lady that wrote it and so that
was the first thing for me where I met
someone who did a thing and I was like
oh like people do this you know like
regular people do stuff like that you
don't have to this isn't I don't know it
just made it suddenly became much more
accessible
I had a similar thing where I was a
little kid running around the woods
using sticks as machine guns and then at
some point I realized you could actually
have that as a job
and I said to myself oh I'm set yeah you
can do this for a living and then I met
one of a guy who was a Marine Corps Joe
instructor who was like the older
brother of a friend of mine and it was
like same thing like okay cool this is a
real thing yes where do I sign up for
this gig and I can go make this happen
well you know this you know what a nepo
baby is that everyone's a nepo baby is
like an actor whose kid becomes an actor
like they're talking about how how many
people that are famous you realize
actually had like famous or wealthy
parents and so it's kind of been this
backlash against that believes but I I
don't think like Steph Curry is not
great because his dad was in the NBA and
that gave him an unfair Advantage I
think it was
partly genetics partly he had access to
the best teachers and teams and whatever
but also he saw his dad go to work at a
basketball arena and that is and he saw
that at an early age so he had a head
start in believing that stuff was
possible that's utterly impossible to
regular people do you know what I mean
like you realize oh just just like I was
probably more likely to have been a
police officer or scorpion because I saw
my parents do it it's not that they they
would have opened doors that would have
made this thing easier it's just like
that I would have seen that as the you
know like the the family business that's
what we're doing yes that's sort of like
the path that we're following but the
Hollywood thing is different though
right A little pressure because they're
getting gigs when their their parents
are you know talking to the director and
being like yo get my kid in there I mean
that's got to be happening I'm sure
that's part of it but if you can't
deliver it you're not getting more of
them right I think so that's true I
think uh yeah sure Tom hanks's kid is in
Band of Brothers right Colin Hanks is in
uh Band of Brothers but he can also
[__] act okay and so but I think it's
you see someone being in a profession
you see someone being a professional at
a thing that as a fan you don't
understand as being a craft you just
like when you're watching a movie you're
just seeing the thing you get lost in
the world you don't see that as you
don't see the process that goes into it
but when you do see the process I think
it'd be it's demystified in a way that
gives you an advantage yeah and
occasionally you see someone that's not
a good actor
and they look bad and you go that's the
only time you realize maybe it's a
little harder than it looks because
everyone watches an actor be like bro I
could go out there and do that what's up
right yeah sure do you not think that
you watch a movie well maybe you you
understand the craft a little bit more I
think a lot of people they just look at
that like oh I'll go up there and give
me the words to say I'll say them we'll
be good let's go give me my money or
maybe you also see people who are bad
who are successful and you know I'm
better than that person yeah I can do
that
yeah you know it's like you meet someone
who's that's the other thing like if
you're a kid you never met someone that
graduated from Harvard you'd think it's
like this it's like Hogwarts or
something then you meet a dumb person
who's graduated from Harvard and you're
like oh this is It's only later in life
you go oh it's not like unattainable it
could have happened right these are
these are still regular people there's a
process you figure it out so you're in
high school your vision is I'm gonna not
have a job I'm gonna do something cool
where I'm My Own Boss type thing but
you're not even sure what it is yeah
so then you apply to Riverside UC
Riverside yeah I wanted to go to Santa
Barbara but then my high school
girlfriend went to Riverside so I made a
brilliant choice
I know I think about it all the time I
met my wife at Riverside so it's it's I
don't have no regrets but I think in
again you're a high school and you're
like do I want to go to don't live in
the Inland Empire or do I live in Isla
Vista and uh did you visit Santa Barbara
yeah several times God
because that place is crazy it's
absolutely insane it's unreal
the juices have all the best land in
California but then you just went to
Riverside you're like yo
um so you show up there what are you
gonna study what are you studying uh
political science
because that was the first time yeah I
like politics I like I think I wanted to
be like a political writer or something
like that
um
but yeah you don't know that's what's
crazy too that you can join the military
at 18. you're so [__] dumb yeah your
brain I mean what your brain doesn't
develop to your 25 yeah so when you're
17 and you're signing the paper you're
just like yo let's go yeah
um
so then what happens so you only go
there for like a year right is that
right for two years two years yeah and
uh that's when I met uh so I became a
research assistant for this guy Robert
Greene who's like one of the greatest
authors of all time and then how did you
hook up with him I was working for this
other author and uh he ran Robert's
website and I was just super like this
has been blogging is just coming out so
what year is this this is oh six
on 506. okay so I was I was I was very
into this I this world where suddenly
because of the internet
it wasn't this sort of New York gate
keeping media it was like if you made
cool stuff people could find it that was
that was just happening then I think
YouTube sold in 2006 or seven so this is
like when the sort of early internet
culture has just happened and I was
looking through your blogs your first
blog is 2007. is that right that's
probably right I think I might have had
another one I had another one that I
started right after I graduated high
school which is to o5 so I'd been
[__] around
um
but yeah something like that okay so you
start working for Robert Greene yeah
this is while you're still in college
this is while I'm still in college where
does he live does he live in L.A or
something yeah he lives in L.A he lives
and you were just doing remote work
before remote work was a thing I was
transcribed well so so basically he was
he needed a research assistant and then
I'd spent that summer the summer after
my sophomore year I was uh I was the
assistant and a talent agency we're into
this movie producer and I was supposed
to go back and he was like um
what if you just didn't go back and wait
this is at the at the talent agency yeah
yeah he was like What if he was like I
need a new assistant
uh would you like to be my assistant and
uh like answer the phone and the
Hollywood system is deranged you start
by answering people's phones and running
their calendar and that's how you
supposedly learn how to be a like a
producer or a talent manager but so I
was working for this person and so I was
on he was like I'll make you into a
talent manager seems interesting and
cool and then I was working for Robert
and Robert was just starting this book
and he needed like a research assistant
like that he would pay and so for me it
was like am I going to go back to school
to hopefully graduate I think I was
going to graduate in three years but I
was I was like am I going to go spend
another year or year and a half in
school to Hope like I was basically
thinking if I grad if I graduated and
these were the two job offers that I had
I would have been like college was a
huge success and so for me it was like
am I gonna go back back and just read
about this stuff happening or am I going
to go do it and I did it and uh so you
became a full-time research assistant
for Robert Greene and what was he
working on 48 Laws of Power uh no the 40
yards of power came out in my 98 I think
so this was he was doing a book called
the 50th law with 50 Cent and I had to
train my first thing was I had to
transcribe like 30 hours of interviews
between Robert Greene and 50 Cent
which was a surreal like super cool
experience it was you know it was a
super cool experience way in the other
direction I heard that and I was like
gosh that's terrible you're like super
cool I was like this is well for me it
was like this is how a book happens yeah
this is how you do the thing this is the
craft of
it's like I was seeing it start with the
raw materials and then I watched like my
favorite author make a book from start
to finish
and so that was I mean you couldn't you
couldn't pay for a class like that yeah
and it's I'm sitting here thinking about
that so I've written the books too and
the books are in my head yeah you know
what I mean which is uh which is kind of
I guess different in a way than
like a Robert Green Book where he's
working with 50 Cent and doing 30 hours
worth of interviews and extracting the
information from that that's like a
different process it's almost like I'm
cooking steak and Robert Greene is
cooking uh a seven course meal and
there's a lot more that goes into it I
think so I mean yearbooks are you so
it's what do you think yeah and then his
books and like mine are
research driven so it's what you know
what is what is the scope of History say
it it's a i you go I'm going to tell a
story from my life to illustrate this
point and the word I does not only in my
first book does the word I really ever
appear so like I'm I'm I'm I'm the I'm
painting a picture and so I have to go
find and this is what I learned from
Robert is how you go find the stuff
yeah because if someone watched me write
a book they would get nothing out of it
they would sit over my shoulder and
watch me type you know what I mean like
that wouldn't be they wouldn't get it
but the process that you're talking
about is actually a process that you
could take if you're gonna write that
type of book yeah like I learned his his
research system I learned all I mean
they would still learn a lot watching
you you work just like the discipline of
doing it and then all the the editing
and the all the decisions that you make
along the way I learned a lot there too
but it was really like first off it was
just it was like it was like going to
college because he was like I I had to
read all the books that he didn't want
to read or I had to read he'd be like I
think there's something in this person's
life story and so I'd have to go read 10
books about
Joe Lewis or something like that and
then I'd have to present to him what I
thought he needed to know about that
person to use for the story that he
wanted to tell yeah that's very cool and
he really must have seen something in
you because
I when I read a book
like for instance I covered a lot of
books on the podcast I could I've tried
to like see oh someone give me an
assessment of this book and I and I
can't get any I can barely get anything
out of it so he must have had a huge
amount of trust in you to be giving you
that much weight of hey look at this and
tell me what's cool about it basically I
think so I mean he's smart about it so
it's like he's doing 95 of it right and
so I'm I'm pursuing the things that he's
pretty sure are going to be a dead end
so it's like if I find something it's
extra or if I don't find something it at
least he he could at least trust me
enough to eliminate something hey
there's not a story about Andrew
Carnegie that works for this book or
whatever
um but it started I mean I it started
just transcribing interviews which was
you know now you can have a I do that
for you but it it took a long time yeah
when you're reading those books for him
are you just going through the
highlighter and pulling out a set of
notes and giving them the high points
and whatever you thought was interesting
yeah so like I would read the book I
would fold and Mark everything that was
interesting and then I would give the
book I would write up a report about it
and then I'd give him the book the copy
that I read and then he would he would
sort of spot check it and then if
something if he found something
interesting then he would go do more
research so it was it was more just like
a probably in the way that you would
have someone give you an intelligence
report like here are the things I think
you should know and then that that's
lighting up your sort of intuition for
what to what to write off or look more
into or to ask for follow-ups and so
yeah but it was really just it it was
like an apprenticeship in how to do the
thing that I knew that I ultimately
wanted to do so you knew that you wanted
to be an author at some point at some
point I think you really figured out
that I want to be an author yeah
yeah I wanted to write books I wanted to
write books like his books got it
okay so how long are you doing this job
for
uh the nice thing about doing it is I
could do it on the side but I mean
probably
six seven years something like that six
or seven years you were doing stuff I
mean I kept doing it even through like
my first books coming out like at some
point he he like he was like you have to
stop and I was like but I don't want
like to me it was like I remember he
would go like Robert would go like
remember you need to send me your hours
and I'd be like yeah yeah sure and be
like no you need to send me your app
like like to me the idea that I was also
getting paid for it was so like beside
the point to me it was like I could call
Robert and ask him a question I'd be
like Robert like how does uh how does
this happen like who makes this happen I
remember once I was like how does the
index work like what is that do you have
to do that you know like I was just so
the whole process is I mean even when
you sell when you sold your first book
it's not like they told you how it works
they were just like here's some money
please come back with the thing that
you've never done before that almost no
one knows how to do and uh by the way
you don't get the rest of the money
unless unless we accept it yeah so it's
this it like when I sat to write my
first book I had such a huge Advantage
because I was like I wasn't I wasn't
like groping around in the dark I didn't
know if I could if I had an idea or the
talent to pull it off but I knew I could
I knew I could get to the end of the
process I didn't know if it would sell
but I knew I could I had no doubt in my
mind that I could do it because I'd I'd
seen it happen
so then as you're doing this when did
you kind of Branch off and start sort of
the marketing thing so there's that the
right am I making the right statement
there because at some point you you
started a marketing company yeah of some
kind so right so I was I was working at
this talent agency and it was cool I was
working with all these different artists
uh and then uh sort of went sideways
there and uh hold on you can't just like
come on the podcast and just say a big
chunk your life went sideways and carry
on it was a surreal experience so I was
this is talent agency this is a talent
went sideways yeah the the talent agency
was fine my position so two so two
things happened so first off I drop out
of college to to work for this guy like
the thing on the thing with Robert was
not like the thing you drop out of
college for it was this this job I spoke
to your parents that you dropped out of
college oh they they disowned me it was
terrible right like they were like what
are you are you saying yeah
um and even though like when I went the
funny thing is I was just actually back
there and uh because I was I spoke at uh
to the seventh regiment in 29 Palms so I
flew in LAX and I drove through and I
stopped in Riverside and I went for a
run and I ran by like the building that
I dropped out of and I remember and I
think this is worth pointing out to
people who because before you make a
life-changing decision you think you
were literally holding your life in your
hands and it's never that right it's
never as scary is you think it's going
to be remember I walked in I think it's
called hinder Hickory Hall and I was
like you know I'm here to drop out of
college like I'd already told my parents
they they were like you know cut me off
uh I'd already told my girlfriend's
parents like it was this terrible thing
and I was so scared and I go in and I'm
like I'm here to drop out of college and
they go
what you know like that's there's no
like that's not a thing that's like what
do you mean they're like fill out this
form you pay forty dollars and uh you
just put your
like your academic status on hold you
take a semester off and then they're
like if you want to come back at the end
of the semester just fill out this form
and if you don't it just tolls for 10
years so like I I spent all these nights
thinking like I was like literally
jumping off of a cliff and like it was
literally a 40 form that I could undo at
any minute and so it's so scary but you
don't know until you do it and by the
way most of life's decisions are like
that yes there's very few decisions in
life that are actually even if you know
a big one is like buying a house even if
you buy a house even when you like worst
case scenario gosh didn't you sell the
house yes and you look you look you lost
some money and it's gonna take you a
little while you're gonna lose all the
money you're gonna lose some like you
know what I mean like you're like I'm
spending three hundred thousand dollars
this is all the money I have in the
world
it doesn't become worthless it's a
mistake you sell the house
your agent gets three percent other
agent gets three percent you're good to
go you're gonna carry on yes there's
very few decisions that are that that
are permanent very few yes so this is a
great example of one yeah you're like
I'm gonna drop out of college that
co-founders for him because we'll see it
in a semester because they've you know
whenever somebody does decide to drop
out of college they're just going yeah I
fill out this farm and we'll see you
next semester no big deal so go to
Europe or whatever it is you're going to
do with your whatever well and I
remember I told the boss that I was
dropping out to work for I was like you
know I was like I don't know if I if I
want to bet like my whole life on this
and he goes he was like when I was in
college I got mono or some he was like I
spent a year in the hospital he's like
do you know how many times this has come
up in my life since he's like zero times
I spent it took five years instead of
four it's he's like if it doesn't work
out it won't work out but uh so I drive
back to Riverside I do all the stuff he
gives me a week to like you know get out
of my apartment pack up find a new
Department do all this stuff and then I
I show up at the talent agency
and he's not there and his old assistant
is still there like the person he was
supposed to let go is still there she
has no idea why I'm there and none of
his none of his his uh Partners in the
business know why he's there and they
you know they're like just sit here and
they sort of call me in and um they're
like so Aaron's in rehab and uh he
checked into rehab and would be
unavailable for the next uh 45 days and
uh the salary that we've negotiated was
uh they were not in agreement so so
basically I thought so I had this relief
of like oh I'm not blowing up my life
and then I got there and I was like
and uh this is a terrible mistake so
that that that was one thing and then
what happened was I was working for
Robert so I always had the 48 Laws of
Power on my desk and I would read it
because I was researching find stuff and
one of the other partners became like
convinced that I was like plotting or
that I was untrustworthy uh because I
was a protege of Robert Greene and so we
we butted heads and and there was there
ended up being this sort of spectacular
blow up where I was I was uh I stormed
out slash was asked to leave and then uh
that was that was the end of my time I
don't seemed like a storm out asked to
leave type of person I don't this was a
weird this is a weird thing he he comes
in he's sort of like an Ari Gold type
you know for Entourage like that flashy
and uh the my boss had asked me to
listen and he was like listen into this
phone call and he was like I want you to
message me like information that I need
to use so that's what I was doing but
you know like the conference call will
say like five people listening or
whatever they're supposed to be five
people on the call but they're six
because I'm listening and uh the boss
goes like uh who who's there you know
who's there I'm like 19 and so I didn't
say anything I was like I froze I didn't
say it I just pretended that I wasn't in
the call and then he he like finds out
that I'm I'm on the call and he storms
in I'm like sitting on my car so he
storms in and guys like I [__] knew
it was you you know he's like you've
been [__] you know all these suspicions
that he had about me not like I wanted
to be on this dumb call and uh he
he starts slamming the door just like oh
like he grabs the door and slams it then
opens it and he's just like trying to
like physically intimidate like this kid
uh so anyways I just got up and left and
that was it that was it that was it for
the talent agent that was that was that
was the end of my career as a as a
future talent agent and and so now
you're just with Robert Greene well uh
right around that time Rob rose on the
board of directors of American Apparel
which is a fashion company he had he was
a strategic advisor to the CEO and so I
met Dove then and uh Dove had been
asking me to come work for him uh as
like sort of an advisor type person and
so what's he doing asking a 19 year old
freaking College Dropout that just got
fired none of it none of it what were
you doing what what what sort of uh Vibe
were you giving off that you were
getting this type of offer I don't know
I think I think this is you know you
know like any young person like older
people think they know how like
computers work and so I think he he
thought that I understood some something
about the internet and online culture
all this stuff that was a big deal yeah
that makes sense then um and so I like I
didn't even have like a title or a badge
I was just like I reported only to this
person and that's how I started there
what you're where was that oh seven oh
eight okay oh 708 so you had already had
like a Blog you had already and he was
able to like look at that and see and
this is when blogger that was a thing
like you were a blogger yes and that
that was enough to have him say all
right you come and work it America so
that was in 2007. yeah they'd just gone
public it was like the hottest fashion
company in the world and uh but it was
also a mess because he hired you know
random 19 year olds off the street
like chaotic places are good if if you
they're good but then they're also
they're only they're also bad or you
wouldn't have an opportunity they're
burning and they're gonna burn out
they're going to explode they're
volatile and they're they're making a
lot of heat but they're gonna they're
gonna explode yeah and so uh
very soon after like you know he was
like Hey take care of this like this
project and then take care of this
project and this project and then give
me an example of like what you're taking
care of uh I think we're spending too
much money on online advertising tell
tell me if that's true or not right or I
want uh people to people don't know
about this that we're doing find someone
online to write about this so it'd be
like these little things and then I
ended up sort of doing kind of an
overhaul of its marketing stuff and then
ended up
it was like so I did what you said you
know who do you want to run it and then
he was like you and so I ended up
running marketing I was basically the
director of marketing in American
Apparel about like 21 22. and what year
so now it's 2009 yeah something like
that dude so I missed so I was in the
military who institutionalized human
that's just been and very large portions
of my life I've no idea what was
happening in the normal world and I
completely missed this whole American
Apparel thing yeah and and not to
mention my fashion my connection to the
fashion industry even though I have a
clothing company right now my connection
to Fashion industry is next to nothing
so I missed this whole American Apparel
thing I didn't know anything about it
and I started looking at it and it's
kind of wild it was wild I went and
looked at all the ads all these
controversy they're they're amazing ads
they're they're amazing ads and totally
controversial borderline borderline
extremely controversial
so that was you running all that I mean
David was a genius uh and all of that
was him and he like he he did everything
right so we had this idea that the
leader should do everything and he did
do everything he was a sort of singular
genius like he was the fit model he was
the designer he was the photographer he
was the CEO he he could sew the clothes
he could do everything but as the
company got bigger and bigger he lacked
the ability to to delegate and your
Genius can only get you so far but it
was I mean it's a totally insane idea
that he threw sheer Brilliance managed
to pull off I mean at one point had 250
or 60 stores in 20 countries
revenues of almost a billion dollars
it was the largest garment manufacturer
in the United States when especially
then the idea that you could still make
clothes in the United States was
as close to blasphemy
as you could possibly get it and like I
remember the reason I worked there I I
didn't give a [__] about fashion I was
like a kid who liked books uh he he was
like come meet me at the factory and so
I go to the factory and he's like follow
me I want to show you something and so
I'm following through the factory like
on the fourth floor it it was it's right
um and Alameda and the and and the 10
there in downtown L.A in this old you
know 100 plus year old building and so
he's walking the floor and as he's
walking the floor these sewing teams
which were like Korean and Mexican and
all every race you could possibly
imagine but garment workers who were
making 15 to 20 bucks an hour which is
insane
um they're the they are highly skilled
they're the best in the world at what
they do they're getting up and they're
cheering they're giving him like a
standing ovation as he walks the floor
of his Factory and it's not like a cult
of personality thing it's a like they
were working in sweatshops the
alternative was literal sweatshops and
here they have health like he built all
that from the ground up when it was not
supposed to be possible and I'm sure you
figured it out with apparel too like
what what he figured out that's so
interesting and I'm fascinated by it
still is like
so Gap makes a t-shirt for 40 cents and
then they sell they sell it for forty
dollars or whatever right he was like
where does that money go you know what I
mean like like you could if you pay the
workers instead of 40 cents an hour
you're paying them 14 an hour that's
only
changing the cost of making the Garment
by like a dollar or two either way the
problem is that that most fashion
companies are in a race to the bottom as
far as price goes but if you make
something cool that people want where
they're not price conscious suddenly all
the ethical compromises I remember he
said once he's like if you're buying a
swimsuit for eight dollars he's like
somebody got [__] right his point was
like who who are you exploiting to get
this thing at the price that consumers
are willing so he you know an American
Apparel teacher was 22 bucks in 2007
which seemed like a lot of money but it
also allowed the company to do cool [__]
and so I was really fascinated by that
the whole story is also kind of a
Breaking Bad Arc where this guy who had
this moral purpose and genius all ends
up imploding that's what my my book on
ego is sort of informed my also I
watched the rise and the fall of that
company but
um it was just I'd never seen anything
like it yeah no it's been awesome you
know we have
probably 450 right now people sewing and
and again I just had a conversation with
someone about this the other day like
the danger of automation you can't
automate selling like cloth is too
particular and too unique every little
piece of cloth is a little bit different
so a human has to do it they're not
going to have a robot that can sew for a
long long time even with all the
advances that they're making right now
so it's got to be humans it's got to be
people and they got to have skill and
they get in there and they this is
another thing we've really demonized
factory work in America and when the
reality is when there's people that
enjoy working with their hands they like
getting stuff done they like to see what
they've produced at the end of the day
it's very rewarding and it's a good job
and it's a career job so it's been
awesome to participate in that and and
grow those companies and be able to do
what you're talking about and pay people
what they should be paid and then on top
of all that
the the environmental stuff like I see a
lot of companies that are out there that
I believe there's a term for it green
washing have you heard of this term yeah
where they say oh well we give this much
money to the environment but they still
make their clothes in a country which is
basically any country but America where
we can dump all of the leftover
chemicals right into the ocean they go
out the Smoke Stack and it just totally
destroys the environment so it's it's
abusive of the workers it's terrible for
the environment and yet we go we're
going to give a little money to the to
the environmental causes it's organic
cotton yeah and it's total [__] so
we're fighting against that and that's
why I was really when I when I was
reading about American Apparel and what
it did it was very interesting for me to
read and yet certainly for for him to be
able to pull that off it's been hard for
us to pull it off and we've done it you
know we've been able to pull it off and
we're going to continue to keep growing
and get bigger and better but uh it's a
very fascinating story and it definitely
parallels a lot of what we're doing
without the like we just have a little
bit of a disc a little bit more of a
disconnection from
um I would say that like the high
fashion type thing we're more mainstream
normal human clothing but that's that
that's a couple things he figured out I
mean so first off it was vertically
integrated so like they he knitted their
own he knitted the fabric cut it dyed it
so so he did and then ran his own stores
so he realized that where where is the
money going if it's so cheap to make
it's all the middlemen along the way
which I which I thought was really
interesting and then his other thing was
okay like do you remember a couple years
ago there's a controversy where like the
CEO of Abercrombie and Fitch the
Abercrombie and Fitch doors when they
would when stuff wouldn't sell they
would cut it up and throw it in the
garbage the clothes and they're like why
could you do that well it's because the
stuff is actually worthless right if it
doesn't sell in the sales cycle it's
worthless and it actually costs more to
ship it back to some warehouse and store
it where by the way it becomes less
valuable every day because it's not like
unless they hold on in for 30 years the
fashion is never coming back and you're
paying to store it yes exactly the
storage which might not seem like a big
deal but it's a big deal yeah and
especially if you're doing millions of
pieces right so what Dove figured out
was hey if you make stuff that doesn't
go out of style you make Classics or
Basics and you don't Venture into [__]
that is trendy you bypass all of that so
you know if you don't sell this blue
t-shirt in March you'll sell it in April
or May and and so he he for the first
seven like decade of the company why it
was so huge is that he sold not just the
stuff that that people always wanted but
stuff that Evergreen Evergreen and that
you would go oh I wore out this t-shirt
I'm gonna go get another one not and you
knew they had the stuff you wanted so
when you make [__] that is perennial
that's Timeless you are not in this
cycle of of sort of planned obsolescence
which is which is not only exploitative
to the customer it's also really hard
because you have to be so right right
like I'll give you an example for for
Daily Show look like I have a calendar
like a page a day calendar and so when I
first did it it was you know January for
Monday January 1st right and then
thinking about something I learned from
Dove I was like wait [__] if I just
don't put the day on the calendar if I
just make it a January 1st calendar I
don't have to guess how many to make
each year and I can make it better and
cheaper and in a less exploitative way
because it's perennial right and so if
you think if if you just take if you
start from not wanting to [__] people
over and not seeing yourself as a
predictor of the future you have such a
wider Target and you can make better
decisions it's like people always are
going to want this they always want
t-shirts and socks and underwear and
whatever and then it was even the point
like if you made a weird if you made a
pink T-shirt people didn't like it
because he owned his own dime he could
send the T-shirt back and dye it a
different color so it was it was a
brilliant thing that could be today a
hugely valuable company but you know he
ended up destroying I don't know what
was the destruction how did the
destruction take place well there's a
huge metoo part of it which is just a
collapse of ethics and and discipline
you know you would have relationships
with employees even though over and over
and over again he was like this not only
is it not okay like it's uh it exposes
the company to all sorts of legal
liability and lawsuits and ultimately
but but the big thing was and I see this
all the time in life so American barrels
is hot huge company but
um Urban Outfitters Forever 21 there
were these other fast fashion companies
that were growing faster that were
getting more media attention and he
started trying to copy them so like
American Apparel had 25 stores in New
York City because they were basics
h m has two and they're big Flagship
stores so it they're in totally
different business models but what
people do is they try to have their
model and do what someone else is doing
and so he started trying to compete with
people who were running totally
different races and abandoned the idea
of only selling classic stuff so he
would try to ride waves of Trends so he
would make something and then uh it
wouldn't sell and then he started to
choke slowly on the inventory but the
big mistake was
making a t-shirt requires
eight sewers making a button up like
this 40 sewers and so Not only was he
switching towards pieces that were less
profitable and
um
less perennial but they would take the
teams off the core efficiency so it's I
mean it's a really Timeless business
story it's like you you you you drift
out of your lane and then you crash and
and that's what it was that was that was
a huge part of it and then it was
lawsuit after lawsuit and then the banks
wouldn't lend on it and then just kind
of spiraled into
I I write about this in one of my books
but he was also like no discipline in
his personal life so never slept he
would call me at three in the morning
just to talk about stuff it'd be like
three three in the morning
his time like he would just call he was
he was a workaholic with no boundaries
and I think he kind of worked himself
almost into like a psychosis like like
just like a like a Howard Hughes kind of
state where you're not
on this planet anymore when you would
meet with him did he listen other people
would he take your ideas would he say oh
yeah that sounds a good idea would would
someone push back on him and or was he
the type of person because I've known
people like this that are so convincing
and so persuasive that even when they're
wrong they win every argument it was
exactly that I remember one time he
called a bunch of like the executives
into the office and it was like a
three-hour meeting like a three-hour
meeting where he talked the whole time I
remember I was leaving and one of the
creative directors who was brilliant and
she'd been there like from the beginning
what was you know because I'm like 20. I
haven't seen it and she goes the thing
about Dove is that Dove wants to be
heard a little bit more than he wants to
be successful
and it was like oh he he he's a
performer and like he's at the end of
the day he wants to
vent and be listened to and go through
the you know he he was like in these
sort of manic rants basically and and
you see like there's lots of we just had
a president who liked to do that right
it's like I'm not here to learn what I
need to learn accomplish what I need to
accomplish delegate what needs to be
delegated it's I need to air my personal
grievances my theories about the
universe you know what it's it is a very
it's it's both a toxic leadership trait
but it's also an intoxicating leadership
trait and what you what I saw happen
it only became clear to me in retrospect
it's like they would like the investors
or Robert who's on the board would like
they'd be like we're bringing in this
new person this like this person's from
Apple this person's from this company
and they would make it like three months
you know and then leave and then what I
realized was happening again to me this
is like how business worked like I had
to unlearn so many Habits Like This was
normal it's like if your parents
screaming at each other all the time
you're like isn't this what everyone's
parents do but I realized they would
show up and go oh
no way this is going to succeed they
knew that this was not how it was done
and so they would leave and so what the
the interesting thing about egotism or
craziness in leaders it's not just that
they make bad decisions but they also
repel people who make good decisions
because they go I'm not going to be
heard this is dysfunctional Life's Too
Short you know they want no part of it
and so it was this kind of constant
shedding of talented operators that he
desperately needed around him and all
that was left was like crazy people
crazy people or wildly unqualified
people which I was in retrospect
obviously what
so what year does it kind of fall apart
did they go BK like what happened to him
in the end so I wrote my first book in
2012 so like I I
I stayed on and was like an advisor like
a sort of uh consultant and so I stayed
on until like 2014 and it was getting
crazier and crazier at one point he sort
of locks himself into this uh this
facility in La Mirada it was like a a
distribution facility like he moves in
there like he has a shower installed in
the office and he's like sleeping there
on this cot and he's going and this is
him trying to salvage what's going on
and trying to if I work harder it was
like you know this is why sleep's so
important he makes a bad impulsive
decision that reflection and uh an
advisory Council would have warned him
against and then instead of backing up
and going [__] I shouldn't have done
that he forces it and then he's like
well I'm Gonna Save thing I'm gonna move
into the facility and he brings every he
brought everyone there even though the
factory was downtown he brings everyone
there they're all commuting to La Mirada
and he's like he just has this basically
break with reality he's losing his mind
the stock price is at like 70 cents and
the banks won't lend because he's been
sued over and over again
and the board had given the board like a
board of directors
people ask like how did so and so get
away with it as long as you're winning
people will let you get away with pretty
much everything and then when it's not
all the defer it's like all the Deferred
maintenance comes to and so uh the board
started to get a sense of what was
happening and then uh they came to him
with an offer they were like look you've
run the company into the ground
but you also Built This brilliant thing
that can't you know exist without you
and um they were like here's the deal
you can resign as CEO and stay on as
creative advisor will pay you a million
dollars a year and you'll keep all your
shares or this is the press release we
are putting out right now about you
being fired for a cause and it is let me
like think about it for a minute he
walks out comes back and he's like I
choose door number three [__] all of you
like uh Wolf of Wall Street just
straight up I'm not lay bad yeah and the
show goes off he he um he assures this
hedge fund that he is of course innocent
of everything he's ever been accused of
uh that he has been you know unfairly
thrown out he pledges them as collateral
all of his shares and says like I need
you to initiate a hostile takeover Strat
drives the company into bankruptcy uh I
I came back after he left uh to to
hopefully like turn things around at the
request of the board which was a grant I
was supposed to be writing ego as the
enemy as this is happening so it was
like the greatest Rings I've seen you
could have possibly imagined and you
know he's basically trying he's trying
to jockey the thing and it's like he
must have in retrospect I think about it
so much it's like not only did he know
where the bodies were buried people like
me also knew where the bodies are buried
because we were there when things
happened like the idea that he was going
to be Vindicated in this process was
delusional and you know he ends up
he ends up driving it into bankruptcy uh
as basically chokes it to death on legal
fees goes into bankruptcy his share has
become worthless he's not cleared in the
investigation by the hedge fund so they
confiscate the the shares the remaining
equity and he ends up owing them 20
million dollars so he goes his shares
were at one point one point worth
something like 500 or 600 million
dollars and uh he ends up negative 20
million dollars
and uh just recently he was uh he is now
in business with Kanye West
he is running Kanye West's fashion like
so it's so far he's now in like the only
person in the world that will do
business with a notorious anti-semite
and Dove is Jewish so it's it's ego
sucks you down like the law of gravity
okay so uh trust me I'm lying
Confessions of a media manipulator
um let me take so this is the book that
you wrote in 2012. you say this
my full-time job then was director of
marketing for American Apparel clothing
company known for its provocative
imagery and unconventional business
practices and I would go on to found my
own marketing company brass check which
would orchestrate stunts and marketing
trickery for other high-profire profile
clients from authors who sell millions
of books to entrepreneurs word for
hundreds of millions of dollars I create
and shape the news for them usually it's
a simple hustle someone pays me I
manufacture a story for them and we
trade it up the chain from a tiny blog
to a website of a local news network to
Reddit to the Huffington Post to the
major newspaper to cable news and Back
Again
until the unreal becomes real
sometimes I start by planting a story
sometimes I put out a press release or
ask a friend to break a story on their
blog sometimes I leak a document
sometimes I fabricate a document and
leak that really it can be anything from
vandalizing a Wikipedia page to
producing an expensive viral video
however the play starts the end is the
same the economics of the internet are
exploited to change public perception
and sell product now I was hardly a
wide-eyed kid when I entered this world
I grew up online and I knew that in
every Community there were trolls and
tricksters like many people I remained a
Believer I thought the web was a
meritocracy and that the good stuff
generally Rose to the top but spending
serious time in the media underworld
watching as the same Outlets who fell
for easy marketing stunts seriously
report on matters of policy or culture
will disabuse you of that naivete
it will turn that hope into cynicism
though I wish I could pinpoint the
moment it fell apart when I realized
that the whole thing was a giant con I
can't
all I know is that eventually I did it's
ultimately what put me on the path to
write this book
so as you're doing all this CR so that's
like a crazy thing to read it must be
when you when you when I read that right
now are you kind of like
it's I have a weird relationship with
that book for sure
because you're sort of a grown man now
who talks about stoicism and telling the
truth and this thing is like you were a
propagandist to make money for Savages
yeah and and to do that you become a
Savage yeah it was weird it was weird it
the whole thing seems like a fever dream
it kind of had that blogger tone too a
little bit your writing style on that
one you know it kind of still feels like
that blogger yeah you know getting out
like a little admission of what's going
on behind the scenes yeah yeah
yeah I mean I would have liked to have
read that book but no one had written it
and so I was like you know what I think
I'm I knew what I wanted to write about
but I also felt like I had this unique
perspective on this thing that had
happened and I was like I'll write about
that first
when you look at media when you look at
advertising now is it all just gross to
you well it's funny like I remember I
was writing that book so I was writing
it in 2011 and I remember telling my
publisher like this has to come out like
right now like this is all going to be
old news like if it's not out soon and
then basically it was like 10 years
early you know like all the things I'm
talking about in that book are really
what we
see and are complaining about today
right like the idea of fake news or
misinformation or disinformation all
like
a big chunk of what I'm talking about is
like what foreign actors do now how they
uh like they found for instance in the
in the 2016 election and with with other
like Russia will create like fake
Facebook groups get people around
certain ideas and then those Facebook
groups will get written about her
um I was talking about that [__] then
which you could do to promote a a movie
or a fashion launch or whatever yeah
like you think what American Apparel
would do I'll give you an example
um we noticed like whenever we would do
a controversial ad that um
that it would get written about so we
get publicity for the the new ad which
is like your dream yeah so
um I remember this one guy uh
he he he
um he was making fake American Apparel
ads like he would he would put them up
and then people would talk about how
American Apparel has a new ad campaign
or was it real or not and I realized oh
no one's even checking right and and
then it turned out it wasn't even real
like he he wasn't even making these in
real life he was just photoshopping them
onto buildings and then he would like
post that he wouldn't post them on
social media and then websites would
write about them and so I was like we
could do that I was like why are we I
was like if if an American Apparel ad is
newsworthy why do we have to pay for it
to run somewhere why don't we just put
it on our website and say this is our
new ad which we would do so we would put
ads on the American Enterprise website
and it would be like a major news story
and it literally was not more than a PDF
and so so that's as a marketing as a
marketer that's like exciting and cool
and crazy and interesting and a
challenge and then you go
the the reporter who's writing about
this ad that does not exist is then the
next day writing about
a political story or a cultural story or
a celebrity gossip or whatever and you
go they don't have like two sets of
Standards right like this is the same
person just relying on the same random
tip that came and so it was this sort of
slow weakening process for me of like
hey look I can sleep at night with what
I'm doing because it's relatively
harmless uh although certainly not so
harmless people would had tried to hire
me many times but
realizing like oh this this is not good
like this is not this is not the world
that
this is if America is a country
where our your leaders are publicly
elected then basically popular opinion
is
the ruler of the country that you live
in right because that's how we find out
about people that's how policies get you
know thumbs up or thumbs down and so it
was realizing that this whole thing was
just like
that I'd peeked behind the curtain in a
way that was very hard to unsee and so I
tried to write a book that was
compelling and interesting but the sort
of the main message was like this is a
warning this is bad this is really bad
and that's um not how the book
ultimately was received well how was it
received well the initial media
attention was like overwhelmingly
negative like like I was the problem and
then what happened is like oh like you
were a scumbag like you're the guy that
was doing this and you're a scumbag you
made all this stuff happen you tricked
us like I did this thing for the book
where there used to be this service it
was called help a reporter out and the
service was like reporters like let's
say they're doing a trend piece on MMA
they'd be like who wants to like who's
an expert on MMA and be like me and so
um I was like well I'll just pretend to
be an expert about a bunch of [__] that
I don't know anything about and let's
see if they actually check if I'm an
expert was this an online service yeah
help a reporterout.com or something like
this yes who's in and so a reporter
would put on there hey I'm doing a story
about about MMA any experts out there
yeah and Ryan holidays whoever whoever
answers first they would talk to uh and
so you know when you read Trend pieces
and they're like so and so says they
love skateboarding or whatever you think
this is like a person they found on the
streets skateboarding but as I found out
as part of this thing like they may not
even own a skateboard right like they
could just say whatever they wanted so I
was quoted in like the New York Times
and Good Morning America I was quoting
every media Outlet you can imagine what
in what as an expert and what about
anything that they want no no anything
that they wanted in that story so if
they're like like let's go to the New
York Times uh it's about the Resurgence
of vinyl records of which I knew nothing
about
and I just gave I just made up this long
answer about vinyl records and there I
am quote the paper of record in the
United States and so I this is something
I'm doing for something like the thing
with vinyl records is you get that sound
quality that you just don't get on a CD
and and also it's something physical
that you can hold and there's a whole
bunch of nostalgia that goes along with
it that's why me and my friends are out
there buying vinyl once again Ryan
holiday you could have been in this
story that's almost exactly what it was
um but like I may not have even made a
real person like this is just an
exchange over you know and and so this
is this is like I'm writing about that's
going like this is not how the sausage
should get made and the media reaction
was uh look at this guy he's [__] up
how the sausage is made not like the
process is bad so that's like reaction
number one is that and then reaction
number two is the book starts to become
really popular with real bad actor I was
gonna say this is like the Anarchist
Cookbook yeah EX for for people that are
wanting to figure out how to do gorilla
type marketing is that girl yeah right
people and just like just not good dudes
where like this is my favorite book you
know
just hear from people you're like oh
that's not I don't like that I don't
want that to be true how long did it
take for you to realize like did you do
a book signing where you were with just
a bunch of sleaze balls started asking
me like hey when you do this like what's
the best way to get people to to buy
into your scam yeah or it'd be you know
you're just
so here's the weird part so I wrote the
book and and it is true that like
people's reputation we call it now
cancel culture that was not a thing then
but people's like reputations will get
ruined from like a random rumor or
something that's not true or something
that's taken out of context so I talk
about that in in the book and Dove Dove
was complicated in that Dove was doing
[__] that he shouldn't have done and
then some of this stuff wasn't true and
so I talked more about the stuff that
wasn't true in the book so the real
thing that slowly affected me on the
book was just like I've probably heard
from every major person who has been
metooed
since the book came out
and they're all 100 innocent when they
call you know what I mean like and it
was this process of it's probably like
what a defense attorney goes through
where you start and you're like
everyone's innocent they're being
railroaded and then you're just like
can't all be innocent and then they're
all guilty you know and you just start
to dislike the clients that you're you
know hired to protect and so it was kind
of just a process for me of like that's
not how I live my life and even when I
worked at American Apparel like I was
with my now wife the entire time I
wasn't interested in any of the
shenanigans or any of the Mischief or
any of that [__] and so that was also
just a process of like people wanting to
use the book
because
they want they wanted it to like they
were just convinced that they were like
the victims when they were really the
victimizers you know what I mean so I
have a weird relationship with the book
and that's been a process also yeah I
mean I wrote it when I was 24. and and
as you're writing it though you kind of
think that you're uh a magician that's
like gonna tell how the magician tricks
work yes and so then you get people that
are like yo why are you telling how the
magician trick works and you also get
people going oh I can use these magician
tricks to like rip people off that's
basically what you did yeah and and you
expect if you if you say how the tricks
work the trick should stop working that
was my thinking like people were like
well why are you talking about it well
I'm like if I lay it all out obviously
all these loopholes will get closed
right like this won't be possible
anymore it'll be a compelling read but
it it's the it's the final chapter in a
lot of this stuff and that's just not
not the case like
there is very little in that book that's
aged
it's some of it's aged badly but it's
all true still and it's Excel has it's
accelerated right obviously because now
even less people get their I mean
social media is the main news source for
most people so it's not even like when I
was talking about how social media would
filter into the mainstream media now
it's now it just is yeah
and anyone like you talking about how
you had to like get it to a blogger and
nowadays you just make up a make up a
Twitter account and just fire something
off and yeah keep your fingers crossed
and now you don't even have to do it
it's like now you could write code that
does it you could have a bot you know
what I mean like what percentage of
tweets or Internet comments or these
extreme things that we we don't get mad
is that person even real
probably probably not yeah or are they
working in some you know computer Farm
in Moscow or something or North Korea
right like foreign Afters have realized
hey like if we can get our we can't
attack America but we can pit Americans
against each other and so what is the
most extreme [__] we can get someone to
say from this side so then people pile
on then people just like how do we make
certain ideas radioactive how do we pit
people against each other
how do we just drive everyone crazy the
more time they're spending on social
media's time they're not spending doing
actual [__] that matters yeah I've been
talking a lot lately about when I was
running the training the Advanced
Training for steel platoons
you want to you want to put them in
Under Pressure situations you want to
see how they're going to perform but one
of the ways you could guarantee that
they were just going to fall apart and
just and just do a terrible job was to
if there was any kind of like a little
little friction or a little fault line
inside the platoon
and if that if they couldn't if if one
of the let's say it's the platoon Chief
versus the platoon Commander
if the if one of them couldn't sort of
subordinate their ego and be like okay
fine we'll just do it your way if they
both just held strong all of a sudden
you'd get this this little fracture
would just turn into a fault line would
just turn into an earthquake and
everything would fall apart and they'd
just be hey they would fight each other
and hate each other and it'd be terrible
anytime you can get a team to go against
itself the team is going to lose yeah
and so it's so clear that that so much
of that is happening in America right
now and we spend so little time going ah
you know Ryan's pretty good guy he
thinks this but he seems like a good
good enough dude I don't know well more
fine instead of going well actually Ryan
thinks this he's an evil person and he
doesn't even understand things and I
know everything and I'm obviously right
about everything so I hate him there was
a there was a thing that really really
hit me home after the book came out
because I live in this little town
called Bastrop Texas
do you remember the Jade Helm 15
conspiracy theory no it was one of the
first Russian psyops before the election
interference and stuff which is
basically through these like Facebook
groups they started this rumor that this
is like maybe 2015. remember there was a
series of like
um uh Army exercises or military
exercises in the southern part of the
United States where they were practicing
for like a Russian invade they're
practicing for like an invasion and
needed they're doing this broad sort of
war game in the U.S and they spread this
conspiracy theory that
um
that the federal government was planning
a takeover of the states which is ironic
because that's what the Civil War was
about and it's already been said it's
like already a settled issue
um but but they started this conspiracy
theory that like starts in social media
then these blogs start talking about it
then news outlets are reporting on how
people are worried about it and then
like citizens or Armin and then uh Greg
Abbott the governor sends the National
Guard to observe the exercises right so
they watched as this fake thing now
suddenly literally the the the National
Guard and the actual Army are like
potentially in a conflict zone right and
and this is a sort of trademark the
kinds of stuff that I was talking about
in the book I mean and this is what I
think when people think cyber warfare
they think like hacking and that can be
part of it yeah you [__] up an
electrical Grid or you know of the
launch of a missile that's but a big
chunk of it is more like in information
cyber tax where you're spreading out
things and getting people riled up about
stuff that's not true yeah that's
all the stuff that you're talking about
in that book is exacerbated now yes and
more true now because we're more online
now yeah like there was I think even
when I was writing that book there was
still distinction between like the
internet and real life and now I mean
just everyone lives
on the internet
disturbing yeah uh your next book that
you rolled into was uh growth hacker
marketing
a primer on the future of PR marketing
and advertising so what same vein I
guess a little less nefarious a little a
little less nefarious
um you say this flashback to 1996 before
Hotmail had launched as one of the first
free Webmail services and became an
early example of a product going viral
as the journalist Adam pennenberg
describes the meeting in his book viral
Loop hotmail's Founders sabir Bhatia and
Jack Smith sat across the table from Tim
Draper the famous venture capitalist he
told them he thought the product
web-based email was great but he
wondered how they get the word out body
is first instinct was that industrial
marketing approach we've been talking
about will put it up on a billion
Billboards or sorry we'll put it up on
billboards he said Draper nicked such an
expensive approach for what would be a
free product so they kicked around more
ideas radio ads same problem what about
sending an email to everyone on the
internet Draper suggested that was the
that was only a slightly newer version
of the old mindset spam doesn't work
then Draper happened accidentally on
growth hacking could you he asked put a
message at the bottom of everybody's
screen oh come on we don't we don't want
to do that but can you technically do it
can you put it can you put it on one
message and if he sends an email to
somebody else you can put it on that one
too right yeah yeah they replied
so put PS I love you get your free email
at Hotmail at the bottom this little
feature changed everything it meant that
every email that Hotmail users sent
would be an advertisement for the
product and that advertisement was
effective not because it was cute or
creative but because it showcased an
amazing product that many people wanted
and needed each you new each user met
new users each email meant more emails
and more happy customers and most
crucial all this could be tracked and
tweaked and improved to drive as many
users as possible into the service
you say that this was revolutionary and
you go on to uh talk about what growth
hacking is a growth hacker is someone
who has thrown out the Playbook of
traditional marketing and replaced it
with only what is testable trackable and
scalable their tools are emails data
targeting blogs and platform apis
instead of commercials publicity and
money while they're marketing Brethren
Chase vague Notions that like branding
and mind share I haven't heard mine
share in a while that's no fun growth
hackers relentlessly pursue users and
growth
and when they do it right those users
become evangelists for products bringing
more users with them growth hackers are
the inventors operators and mechanics of
a self-sustaining self-propagating
growth machine that can take a company
just not just from zero to one but from
one to a hundred or a hundred million
so what was the what made you decide to
write this book I I was uh I was
interested in this sort of group of all
those big companies that were now
multi-billion dollar companies you know
they basically launched with no
marketing whatsoever
and they grew faster than any company
has ever grown and sort of what are the
lessons and then I mean I think about
your Brands right like if
an established like consumer package
goods company was going to launch any of
the stuff you did and they were like
well what's that going to cost
10 million 100 right like the whole
thing would have been at a at an almost
incomprehensible skill and almost
certainly would have failed like what
what's their what's their hidden
percentage it's extremely low and then
you look at these people who have built
these huge Brands off the back of a
single Instagram account or a YouTube
channel or you know like and so I was
just really interested in how like the
game had sort of fundamentally changed
like what what Don Draper was doing in
Mad Men is not how marketing works today
I mean it's it works once you it's still
kind of what you do at a at a very high
level like once you're already huge but
when you're building something from
scratch which is what most of us are
doing right we're trying to launch a
coffee shop or a book or a brand or yoga
studio or whatever it is we're starting
from zero so it's really like how do you
go from zero to those first people
and uh why don't we learn from like the
best people that have ever done and that
idea of growth like one of Facebook's
early decisions is they didn't have a
marketing department they had a growth
Department that seems like a kind of a
semantic difference
but like a marketing department does
marketing
and a growth Department Grows Right like
just the word there is is illustrative
and uh you know marketing is like we're
gonna throw a Premiere party and we
bought everyone t-shirt you know it's
it's all this stuff that's cool we're
gonna have a booth at the Sundance Film
Festival or what right it's stuff that's
cool for the marketers but nobody knows
if it works or not and uh so it's all
about that that's what it's about and
that book that book what's weird about
that book is it kind of proved that that
book started as an article then it
became an ebook then it was a paperback
and then it was an extended I think it's
on it's like third or fourth edition so
it's kind of a weird it's also not how
books really work when you wrote uh when
trust me online came out what
that come up through a traditional
publisher yeah yeah and you got a book
deal how did you get that book deal uh
um I got an agent I knew Tim ferriss's
agent uh so we have the same agent Steve
and uh I just went and I I didn't need
the money so I just wrote I wrote the
book I was like this is the book it's
coming out regardless uh and then I I
saw I showed it to him and asked him if
he thought it could sell and it did it
so it sold at an auction
it was this big thing it was funny
actually then then we put out what the
Publishers at an auction yeah yeah it
was like a it was a hot book okay which
was pretty cool at like 24. but then the
funny thing is when I announced it I
just doubled the size of the advance I
just said you know I said I got paid
like a half a million dollars for it
which I didn't but nobody checks press
releases and uh so then then the the
thing got a bunch of press as this like
huge book coming up and sort of proved
my point
um but uh but yeah so then so then did
you do all your viral marketing for that
book yeah yeah and how did it do it sold
really well uh it sold really well
um it got a lot more attention than its
own copies but
uh it's it sold really well and then uh
the growth hacker book came out and then
then uh I went to my publisher and I
said actually I don't remember the exact
time but at some point I've done these
marketing books and I went to my
publisher and I was like for my next
book I'd like to write it about an
obscure School of ancient philosophy and
they were like what you know it was like
a record scratch thing and uh that was
that was the big sort of pivot it it
felt like a pivot to them to me it was
always what I wanted to do
when you are uh doing this
doing marketing these two books right
here
it seems like you have to be good at
marketing these books and do well with
them otherwise it's kind of like you
know why are you teaching us about this
stuff that's what I told him I was like
I was like watch me proof I was like
watch me prove it with this book which I
which I did and so you pulled it off
yeah you pulled it off with both those
books did you did so did growth hacker
marketing eventually come out on a
traditional publisher so uh yes yes it
did I'm actually all my books are with
the same publisher except for my kids
books because you gave me some advice on
self-publishing right on um but yeah all
of them are traditional colors uh and
what about uh Tim ferriss's book this
the four hour Chef yeah what was your
involvement with that so I met Tim right
before I dropped out of college actually
um
2007 at uh at South by Southwest and we
kind of became friends and um so I
worked on the marketing on all of his
books
um and uh I mean it took that job
because I wanted to learn from Tim which
I learned so much from because he's a
genius yeah
um and you I just watched those things
become just absolute monsters
um but yeah we did the marketing for but
that was a weird book though because it
was the book that came out on Amazon
publishing and he got hated by every
other normal publisher and they wouldn't
carry it in bookstores it was Mayhem
yeah basically got basically all the
retailers teamed up and said why would
we carry a book from our biggest
existential threat and so we ended up
doing this thing where we gave a huge
chunk of it away on BitTorrent which was
like a piracy website and uh and so like
Millions but millions of people
downloaded in the you know the book sold
super well it was weird so I met Tim and
Tim is to blame for like everything that
I do right now so good job Tim
appreciate it but when I met Tim the my
first book hadn't come out yet
and the things that he was saying to me
I was you know like thinking okay yes
okay you know because he'd done really
well
and it was so weird that my publisher I
mean my publisher is now
what has it been almost eight years
later they're now more for lack of a
better word hip to what's going on yeah
but at the time they what the how far
ahead strategically Tim Ferriss was in
2015 was was was crazy for example
he said he's like I'm gonna put this
podcast so my book was coming out
extreme ownership was coming out October
20th or something like this and he says
yep he's like okay this is the podcast
is because I recorded a podcast my first
ever interview with him he's like I'm
gonna put the podcast out September or
whatever late September and I said he
said that way we're gonna get a bunch of
pre-sales on Amazon he had this whole
this whole thing and so I talked to my
publisher and and they said they said
can you get him to put the podcast out
the the week of book launch and I was
like I'll ask him and so I said hey man
they really want you to put this out on
the week of the book launch and he's
like that's because they have no idea
what they're talking about yeah and he
was just so right because I've now have
done it a bunch of times and he he was
just so right and he just knew he had so
much strategic insight as to what was
happening compared to what the
traditional book publishers and look
there's some great people I I have a
team there that has helped me launch a
bunch of books they've done a great job
but he definitely was ahead of the power
curve when it came to how to get this
[__] done right I think what Tim is
Tim's special skill
Tim's special skill is that he figures
out like he deconstructs the system
before he does anything so he figures
out like what actually moves the needle
what actually works what the logic of
the world that he's operating in and
then he's like where do I have an
advantage what are people not taking
advantage of you know and he does all of
that so like I'll give you an example
he's also to blame slash uh the the
beneficiary for me on all the stuff that
I've done like my my first couple books
came out and they did all right but then
I remember I was we were both at this
conference in Amsterdam and I was
working on the obstacles way
and I gave him the I was like he's like
what are you working on I'm like I'm
working on this book about Stoke
philosophy because he and I both were
really into it and uh he was like let me
read it and uh so I gave it to him and
he's like let me buy this I was like
what do you mean that's already sold to
a publisher and he's like no let me buy
the audiobook rights this was in
2013. before audio was like before
audible was huge and Tim was like let me
buy the audiobook rights and I think he
bought the audiobook rights from my
publisher for like five thousand dollars
and
um
and my my publisher was like absolutely
not uh you know terrible idea we want to
do it or
it's either that or they didn't even
care but I remember being and I was like
just let Tim do whatever he wants he
knows what he's doing and obviously my
agent uh sort of brokered it all because
he works with both of us Tim buys the
audiobook rights he I think I'm the
fourth episode on the on the podcast I
think he launched it to promote this
audiobook publishing arm that he did he
basically just went and bought the
audiobook rights to a bunch of his
favorite books knowing audiobooks were
going to be huge and then more
importantly he also knew that audible
paid like a 50 referral bonus for any
new subscriber to audible so he knew
like Not only was he recommending the
book that he owned the rights to but if
you joined Audible for doing it he got
like a huge cut of your like commission
so so he works all this out
and I mean the audiobook of the
obstacles wait sold hundreds of
thousands of copies and he bought the
then I think my next two also but what
Tim realizes he was like basically
I'm blowing people up on my blog he was
like I'll just take a stake in the
things yeah and and so he he just did
that and he every
every time I remember at South by
Southwest Twitter launched like that was
the year that Twitter launched what year
was that 2007 and I was like this is the
dumbest idea in the world and Tim
invested in it so Tim Tim has an eye for
whatever is going to be huge uh and he
he he figures out like what resources
are under exploited or undervalued and
that's even his investing like obviously
he's a big investor but he also realized
like Angel Investing is the most
efficient way to invest because you
don't put in a large amount of money and
so he was able and he also understood I
think there's a little bit of status
Arbitrage there that like
he was he's just a genius at figuring
out where stuff's going and he gets in
very early and that's why I mean that's
why he's huge yeah yeah he told me to
sign up for Twitter and he's he said hey
you really should go on Twitter it's a
great way to get information it's a
great way to meet people and all this
and get connections with people that you
wouldn't otherwise connect with and he
and I said well I don't know how to do
it he's like don't worry I'll show you
I'll show you how to work it and I'll
show you I'll I'll work you through it
and he I signed up for it he never told
me a damn thing about it
I mean he was early on podcast he was
early yeah social he's been or but he
did tell me he's like it's you don't
have to be first you just have to be
early so he lets people kind of figure
it out he he like there's been very few
where Tim has been wrong do you know
what I mean like like he doesn't he's
not like
he's not just like picking a thousand
horses and some of them win he he waits
till just it's like just sure enough and
then he Dives in and he jumps in with
two feet and and then he [__] crushes
it yeah no he told me to start a podcast
too like as soon he pressed stop on the
recorder I remember we were just at his
house in in San Francisco at the time or
and he pressed stop and he looks at me
he said you should start a podcast and I
was like
okay yeah you know and then Rogan told
me the same thing but it was it was Tim
just like press stop looked at me and
said you should start a podcast and you
know like thank God he told me that
because I listened to him
um yeah that's pretty wild so you're
doing so you had helped with his
marketing on all of his books yeah and
then you start with the obstacle the way
now how long had you been into stoicism
for I found Stills and before I dropped
out of college so it was I when the
obstacles away came out I would have
been 2014 so
yeah a while what was the what was the
connection to it I read Mark
surrealist's meditations which is just I
think one of the most incredible and
unique historical documents to ever
exist yeah it's amazing right like the
most powerful man in the world
maybe the wisest man in the world at
that time is writing private notes to
himself on campaign with the Roman army
about what he needs to do to be better
as a human being and as a leader and and
to not be corrupted by the power that he
holds and he never intends it for
publication
and somehow Against All Odds like 20
centuries later we can read it yeah it's
it's a miracle I mean it's just and
there's nothing in every one of my books
and your books we're writing there's
some performative element for it right
like there's some it's not false but
there is something in it where you're
writing for the reader what's so raw and
authentic about meditations is that it's
for him yeah it's interesting I've been
asked since the
first probably five within five podcasts
and I'm on 394 right now people like oh
are you gonna cover Mark Australia's
meditations
and there's actually a legitimate what I
think is a legitimate reason why I
haven't done it oh the legitimate reason
is if you read public if you read
meditations you need no further
explanation there's I could read them to
you but I have nothing else to say
really about every one of the statements
and you go yeah that stands on its own
and this stands on its own and this
stands on its own and that's why I've
never taken the time I I suppose I will
at some point just maybe have a
conversation around around it but it is
so self-evident what he is saying in
there maybe it's because of what you
just said maybe because it's not
performative it doesn't take any it
doesn't take any discussion to uncover
anything else it is what it is well
that's what what's interesting about
stoicism is like stoicism has been this
philosophical tradition for 2300 or so
years
that some of the wisest smartest most
powerful people used it was wide wildly
popular in the ancient world why is it
not
more popular in academic life right and
the answer I think is that it's hard to
specialize in the study of stoicism as a
philosopher at Harvard or whatever
because it's all [__] there yeah you
know there's no theories about what
Marcus was thinking or didn't mean this
it's like he said what he means and it's
so boiled down and stripped of artifice
or pretension like there's no paradoxes
or con like the only Paradox is that
sometimes he says this and sometimes he
says that right and people go oh does he
contradicting himself and it's like to a
practical regular person you go
sometimes you do this and sometimes you
do that right like it it's just so
simple and accessible and real like they
weren't like how do we know if we're not
living in a simulation or not or like
how do we know if if there's such thing
as good or or evil right like it's just
it's just
practical real [__] about what it is to
be a person in a world where the vast
majority of what happens is outside your
control
did you
so you read it in high school I read it
my freshman year of college did you
start to
apply them in your own life
obviously somewhat Hit or Miss uh I
think I think I think what struck me at
19 was like
the passage about getting out of bed
early in the morning you know like in
the opening of book five and meditations
he's like
at dawn when you awake and then he
interrupts himself and he goes uh but
it's warmer here and he goes is this
what you were put here on this planet to
do to huddle under the covers and stay
warm like the most powerful man in the
world is having a debate with himself
about whether he should get up early or
not and so I think that strikes you if
you're a human right like you're like
that's me you know maybe not you but you
know I've said the same thing and this
is another thing that's been interesting
for me so uh you and I once again we
were talking before we hit record
I didn't read like when I was growing up
I was uh I was an I was a knuckle
dragger I was not you know my my
mom was English teacher my dad was a
history teacher my
you know they were my mom read all the
time my Dad read seven newspapers a day
uh they were just very into reading they
were teachers you know that's what they
did and I was not I don't know I can't
think of any books that I actually read
in high school and
I I don't think I actually read any
books in high school I might have read
one or two you know for some English
class or something like this and I
apologize to uh my English teachers that
I didn't didn't do it but I just wasn't
into it I was gonna go in the military I
was you know I just it just didn't seem
to be something that I needed to get
done
uh in fact at one point my mom was was I
was already in the Navy and it was
probably like you know like a year into
maybe two years into the Navy and my mom
says like oh have you read any good
books lately
and I said well no
I said why would I need to read a book
she said well it might be interesting I
said if it's interesting they'll make it
into a movie and she said well what if
they don't make it in a movie and I said
if they don't make it a new movie it
wasn't that interesting that's how much
of an idiot I was
it wasn't until I went to it was so so
then
as I was moving up through the ranks in
the SEAL Teams and I eventually realized
how important writing was and so I
started really focusing on it and and I
also started reading military history
books like a hundred percent solely
nothing else because I could relate to
it because I was like oh this is about
war this is what my life is supposed to
be like and then when I went to college
I knew that becoming a good writer would
really help the guys that worked for me
because you got to write awards for them
you got to write evaluations for them
it's you got to write concept of
operations like you write all the time
if you're an officer in the military and
so I wanted to get good at it and that's
why I studied English and then I started
to read and then I started to read all
the time and and I remember when I was
in college you know I one semester I
took five English classes because I was
an English major it was horrible but I
mean that's you know I'd be reading for
eight hours and I also contrary to high
school when I was in college
and I was in I went to college after I'd
been in the Navy for eight years so I
was a grown adult human I would read I
read every single assignment that I got
a hundred percent like I read every
single page of every single assignment
that I ever got in college which is I
don't think I don't think there's very
many people at all that do that and I
don't even know if it was that smart but
that's what I did so I started reading
all the time then but
like when I started the podcast and I
started getting interviewed and I'd get
people asking me about
you know philosophy I remember I was on
stage one time and a guy said who is
your you know of all of all philosophers
who's your favorite philosopher and my
answer was I said let me you know of
Motorhead because I just didn't I didn't
I didn't have it and as people started
saying oh Jocko's writing is is you know
it's very stoic writing and even what
you're just talking about getting out of
bed in the morning I have written about
that a ton of times and it's all the
same but I didn't know yeah and
eventually I did a podcast about it
because you know it's like oh you talk
about the same thing that Sun Tzu and
the same thing that Mark australius and
well if you put a human
into certain environments like war or
leadership positions and they look
around and they they make some mistakes
and they learn from it they make some
other mistakes and they learn from
eventually you're gonna get to some
place that's
it's a normal place to end up and that's
kind of where I ended up and then I
looked around and said oh my gosh you
know like these guys been talking about
this for so long I wish I wish I would
include on that when I was younger but
of but that's where you end up you end
up saying oh
discipline equals freedom I I I said
discipline equals freedom for the first
time I remember I'd brief it to these
Junior officers this is like Circa 2007
2008. I couldn't have told you one thing
about stoicism and yet I wrote I would
tell these guys if you want freedom in
your job in your life you need to have
discipline
you know maybe I got some of it from uh
from Black Flag Henry Rollins because I
grew up you know listening to listening
to Black Flag and hearing Henry Rollins
talk about discipline but I realized oh
yeah that discipline that he's talking
about if you apply it to your life
you'll end up with freedom in your life
and discipline equals Freedom this is so
and I then I realized oh it applies to
your team too like if you have a
disciplined platoon they're going to be
able to operate with much more with with
much more hands off and they can make
things happen quicker so it was very
interesting to me to kind of arrive at a
place
that
is it's where you're going to end up
it's where you're gonna end up if you
get put into war you get put into
leadership positions you make some
mistakes you learn from them you put you
make some other mistakes you learn from
them you live a life it's it's where you
hopefully end up I think this is why
stoicism in Buddhism for instance have
so many similarities is that if you boil
The Human Condition The Human Experience
if you boil history down
enough times you're not left with that
much you're left with basically this
idea that we don't control what happens
but we control how we respond to what
happens and that these events are
opportunities to to like be great to be
excellent right uh and that that's like
the core that's the core of it and I
think that's what struck me reading
Marcus really for the first time is like
when people hear philosophy they think
impractical they think theoretical they
think abstract they think
incomprehensible right they think like a
college professor talking about
interesting ideas but that that don't do
anything but confuse you and then you
read meditations you read Santa Clara
you read Epictetus in their leg
life is [__] hard here's what you can
do about it like here like uh don't lose
your temper try to be a good person you
know uh Epictetus is asked to basically
boil all of stoicism down as simply as
possible and he says I can do it in two
words uh what's actually three but he
says I can do it in basically two terms
persist
resist some things you need to keep
doing and some things you need to stop
doing right like that's it it's not that
complicated right and this is why the
Golden Rule appears in all the different
religious Traditions it's like there's
not that much stuff it's so it really
just comes down to like who can say it
the most clearly and then who or which
tradition does a good job
of living up to it right like and that's
what I think so interesting about Marcus
really is the most powerful man in the
world literally worshiped as a god
commands the Roman army has unlimited
wealth and you know this is supposed to
corrupt absolutely she has the absolute
power like it's not that power corrupts
it's that absolute power corrupts
absolutely and then you kind of have
this exception to the rule and he writes
about it in meditations he goes be
careful not to become caesarified and
not to be stained purple because the
Roman Emperor wears a purple cloak and
it's like oh yeah maybe it didn't happen
for him because he was meditating in his
journal about making sure that that
didn't happen like he was he was working
on it and philosophy was a way to do
that he also writes in meditation he
says fight to be the person that
philosophy tried to make you into and
you're just like oh yeah this is like a
pep talk from this is a pep talk he's
having with with it with himself about
living up to his potential as a virtuous
person that he's almost certainly
struggling to in the midst of
frustrating annoying obnoxious life
so 2014 you you write the obstacles the
way here's a here's a section from that
in the year 170 at night in his tent on
the front lines of the war in Germania
Marcus Aurelius the emperor of the Roman
Empire sat down to write or perhaps it
was before Dawn at the palace in Rome or
he stole a few seconds to himself during
the games ignoring the Carnage on the
floor of the Coliseum below the exact
location is not important what matters
is that this man known today as the last
of the five good Emperors sat down to
write not to an audience for publication
but to himself for himself and what he
wrote is undoubtedly
one of history's most effective formulas
for overcoming every negative situation
we may encounter in life a formula for
thriving not just in spite of whatever
happens but because of it
at that moment he wrote only a paragraph
only a little of it was original
almost every thought could in some form
or another be found in the writings of
his mentors and Idols but in a scant 85
words Marcus Aurelius so clearly defined
and articulated a Timeless idea that he
eclipses the great names of those who
came before him it is more than enough
for us
quote our actions may be impeded but
there can be no impeding our intentions
or dispositions because we can
accommodate and adapt
the Mind adapts and converts to its own
purposes the obstacle to our acting
and then he concluded with the powerful
words destined for maxim
quote the impediment to action advances
action
what stands in the way
becomes the way
in Marcus's words
in Marcus's words the secret to an art
unknown as turning obstacles upside down
to act with a reverse Clause so there's
always a way out or another route to get
where you need to go so that setbacks or
problems are always expected and never
permanent making certain that what
impedes us can Empower us
and then you go on to say there are a
few things to keep in mind when faced
with a seemingly insurmountable obstacle
we must try to be objective to control
emotions and keep an even Keel to choose
to see the good in a situation to steady
our nerves to ignore what disturbs or
limits others to place things in
perspective to revert to the to the
present moment to focus on what can be
controlled this is how you see
opportunity within the obstacle it does
not happen on its own it is a process
one that results from self-discipline
and logic and that logic is available to
you you just need to deploy it
the obstacles the way
that was very cool to be honest uh this
is you know one of my I think it might
be the most popular clip I've ever made
is this clip from the podcast called
good right and I'm telling a story about
this is something that I was saying
again before I had any recognition of
any of this stuff I was telling my
junior platoon Commander Seth Stone hey
something's going wrong good now we have
an opportunity to overcome it and all
there it is you know it's like there it
is there's no wonder people relate to it
it's one of those things that's been
boiled down over time and it's just true
when we can imagine that he knew it from
experience you know it's like hey we
just found out this you know we just
received news of this setback where this
person just defected or you know this
person just died right he's he's the
emperor would be nobody brings good news
to the emperor right it's just going to
be bad news after bad news especially
for Marcus's ran it's it's kind of
tragic you have this philosopher king
he he inherits the throne from a man
named antoninus Pius there's basically
20 years of peace and prosperity and
then Marcus's Reign there's a plague the
antonine plague there's
series of historic floods almost the
entire almost in the entire reign of
Marcus rios's time is is at War a series
of border skirmishes and he buries six
children like it's one thing after
another for this guy and
and it's not that it's good right like
that he would have chosen it that he was
happy that it happened but it was an
opportunity for him to deploy the ideas
in stoicism you know what I mean like I
think when people hear the obstacle is
the way it's like oh this is going to be
great for my business like no your
business might just barely survive right
or it might go out of business but it
can be good for you as a human being
like you can learn something from it you
can grow stronger from it you can
practice forgiveness or acceptance like
like when we say that everything's an
opportunity yeah a good chunk of the
time the opportunity is like humility or
acceptance or learning from your
mistakes it's not magically a
springboard to exactly where you want it
to go like sometimes life [__] kicks
you in the chest like a thousand times
and and and when we say the obstacle is
the way it's that it's an opportunity to
practice virtue and Excellence inside
that shittiness yeah I've had I've had
to brief quite a few people on that over
the year years in terms of taking
ownership of things yeah and they think
oh well you said if I take ownership you
know that wouldn't be a problem like no
you did something wrong you have to take
ownership that doesn't mean the problem
went away you still have to solve the
problem or or fix the problem or say
you're sorry and make amends and do
things to win back the trust that you
broke like yeah all that starts with
ownership ownership doesn't make
problems go away they just uh it just is
a place to start when a lot of times
ownership as a leader is owning [__]
that's not your fault you didn't screw
up you didn't choose to be to for it to
happen in this moment that you just sunk
your life savings into something and
then a pandemic happens or you know
there's a strike or some you know if you
don't choose any of that but it's still
like it's your [__] problem and and
you you have to go well how is this
problem gonna make me better yeah and
I've always we've had a very interesting
experiences you know we'll work with
companies we work with companies uh a
consulting company called front we have
a bunch of companies that we work with
most of the time it's probably gone up I
used to say 80 or 85 of the time now
it's probably 95 of the time where I
work with companies that actually are
doing well and they just want to do
better and they bring us on to help them
with their leadership
five percent of the time we're getting
brought in by some external component
like let's say the board who says hey
this company is failing can you go help
them
can you get their leadership in order
and the reception that we get in the 95
percent of companies that are doing well
is like Hey we're so happy you're here
we want to learn from you and the reason
that they're doing well is because
they're humble enough to say when the
market shifts they go oh we didn't judge
that well here's an adjustment we can
make or the competitor did this and they
didn't expect it so now they got to
counter that by doing this move and they
admit that they got you know the
competitor got a one-up on them
when the board brings us in because the
company's failing
their reaction is like well we're only
failing because the competitor did this
and the market did that and the union
said this and our investors did that
it's never their fault that's why
they're failing because they don't
change anything because they don't think
it's their fault so when you're in a
leadership position
it actually is your fault it actually is
your fault when something goes wrong and
you didn't plan for it or you didn't
predict it and you didn't have a backup
you didn't have a contingency it's your
fault and by the way that means you have
the ability to say okay I made a bad
call here's where I thought was going to
happen this is what actually happened
here's the adjustments we're going to
make so letting your ego blame other
people is a complete disaster and
doesn't work one of the most beautiful
passages in meditations at the beginning
Marcus lists his debts and lessons like
what he learned from all the people in
his life and he has this he becomes
emperor in kind of a remarkable process
right like he his dad is not Emperor he
comes from no royal family it's that
Hadrian there's basically five male
Emperors in a row that don't have a son
at or in some cases any children and so
Hadrian is getting old uh and he he sees
something in this boy Marcus Aurelius
who is sort of unfailingly honest and
decent and he wants him to become king
but he's way too young and he thinks
that's the worst thing you can possibly
do to someone so he adopts this guy
antoninus who was
like one of the most respected
politicians in Rome and actually what
SEALs it for Hadrian is he watches no
Anthony's doesn't think anyone's
watching and he watches antoninus help
his elderly father-in-law up a flight of
stairs and he goes this is this guy is
it so he adopts antoninus who in turn
has to adopt Marcus Aurelius so he sets
in motion this succession plan and
Hadrian probably thinks you know
antoninus will live for like five or six
years and then Marcus well antoninus
lives for like almost two and a half
decades after that and it's one of the
longest running Emperors just that alone
so Marcus gets like 20 plus years of
apprenticeship under a great man and it
goes both ways I mean like antoninus
could have very quickly killed Marcus
Aurelius that's what you might expect to
happen or or Marx realist could have
tried to kill but instead they decide
like no let's let's really do this like
I want to learn from you I want to teach
you and they have this beautiful
relationship and in the beginning of
minute occasions Marcus lists all the
things that he learns from antoninus and
it's one of the most beautiful
encapsulations of what makes a great
human being and a great leader he's like
he teaches me
how to how when to listen to experts
when to seed the floor how to be
unostentatious how he he he even learns
he's like anthonitis would plan his
bathroom breaks so that he could be more
efficient at the job you know he just
lit all the stuff that he just learns
from this great man and and you get the
sense that Marcus
when he does become power and suddenly
there's no check on him whatsoever the
main thing is he doesn't want to let
this guy down he doesn't he wants to
follow in the tradition that he was
raised in and it's just this it's this
beautiful again totally unique
historical situation of which Marcus
adds a cherry on top so
Marcus gets a stepbrother as a result of
this and uh he names his stepbrother
co-emper the first thing he does with
absolute power is it gives half of it
away which again has never happened and
will probably never happen again and and
it's just I mean there's just so much
there's so much you can study from this
person and uh
yeah I'm just I remain endlessly fat
even all these years later just every
time I think about it every time I pick
it every time I pick up meditation I get
something else out of it I'm like
oh how did you know how did you know
even even
um
even during covet like I didn't really
think of meditations as a plague book
but he wrote it during a 15-year plague
that soldiers brought back from the
Eastern edges of the Empire so it sounds
a little familiar right uh and uh he
goes he's there's two types of plagues
there's one that can take your life and
he's like that's pretty bad and then
he's like one that can destroy your
character and he's like that's the worst
one and uh you just realize like oh [__]
humans were exactly the same during
covid as they were during the antonine
plague and always have been and always
will be and that's what that's what's so
cool about philosophy is like the
timelessness of it or that yeah ego is
basically the plot of every Greek play
and tragedy
flash forward to every superhero movie
like it's just ego that's the main thing
what was your as you're working at
American Apparel I mean how did your
stoic philosophy line up to like this
Mayhem that's going on there well I
think just generally a philosophy of
like discipline and ethics and and uh
like
trying to be a decent person I think
that that that that kept me out of
trouble so so did being effectively
married uh but I think
watching someone who had not absolute
power but just watching the way that
wealth and power and busyness and all
that just watching the way that can warp
someone's Soul uh it's pretty
it's pretty Timeless and real and also
super scary you know to watch someone
that picked like Dove saw me and was
like I see something of myself in you
and then to watch him spin off the
planet that was that was a real head
[__]
when I introduced the topic of the ego
and I'm talking to companies and people
um
I talk about what a threat it is and
then I explain that there's countless
examples throughout military history
where someone's ego drove them to make
decisions that got
thousands if not tens of thousands of
people killed
and in many cases themselves killed so
they would rather die than admit that
they were wrong rather die than than
subordinate their ego to someone else
rather die than change their plan
because it's the plan they came up with
and I say listen if people will die for
their ego trust me you can you can like
overrule someone because you don't you
don't like the way they looked at you
and that's all ego so that's that's a
scary thing I mean MacArthur was this
close to world war three
that's close
and that's not a new I mean he was he
had the same job as so many of the Roman
generals who did this exact same thing
right like the the overreaching is is
the thing is a great um epictetious
quote he says remember it is impossible
to learn that which you think you
already know so on the on the one hand
there's there's the ego of um of the
overreach of the like super talented
egotist but we we forget all the sort of
Silent casualties of ego who we never
hear of because they never got like they
just got fired like on their first day
or they never graduated from like they
never made it because like nobody could
teach them what they thought they
already knew like we think of the
egotistical rock star like destroying
their career but what about the one that
blew up the record deal before it was
even signed because they're just a dick
um
I was once again talking about ego when
we would fire ACL leader from a
leadership position we would fire a seal
leader not because they didn't know how
to read a map not because they didn't
know how to shoot their weapon we'd fire
them because of their ego because they
lack humility now when you lack humility
you don't listen to anybody else you're
just gonna you're just gonna implode and
it's it's absolutely terrible and I also
tell people
you look everyone's got some natural
amount of leadership capability
different levels different skill sets
some people are good at simplifying
things some people are very articulate
some people have a loud voice and it's a
commanding presence like oh let's get
different levels of those and any of
those you can get better in those
categories you can improve in some way
unless you're
an egomaniac or you lack humility and
then then I really just can't help you
like you're just gonna be a terrible
person and a terrible leader and you're
not gonna get any better because you
don't listen to anybody else and you
think you're perfect so going back to
Epictetus you can't I can't teach you
anything if you already think you know
it you're just screwed well it's like if
you think you know everything you're
right
because you can't learn anything else
yeah and if you think you're perfect you
also can't get any better it was so
weird to deal with guys with big Egos
and look in the steel teams you've got a
lot of healthy egos myself included like
you're not you don't sign up and go do
the the quote hardest training in the
world because you don't think you can
make it no you're like I'll do this
let's go but then you roll in with some
of these guys and you you can just see
the look on their face
and doesn't matter sometimes they're
senior to you sometimes they're Junior
to you it doesn't matter you're looking
at them and you can see that what you're
saying they they do not think they need
this information and they know better
than you and and so you go okay well
maybe it's my ego and you say okay we'll
explain your perspective and you realize
that they their perspective is the only
thing in the world to them and they end
up getting fired that's the way it works
it's terrible I've gotten to work with a
lot of sports teams I know you have too
and that they all talk about like you're
the best in the world until you got here
and so that's you know and then can you
do you have if you have confidence you
can become good again if you have ego
you will get destroyed because now all
of a sudden you're getting your ass
kicked you don't know what you're doing
it doesn't feel natural like Shaka smart
he's a great basketball coach at
Marquette he was talking about how
people go like they always quit the
players always quit because it's not fun
anymore and he's like the game is the
exact same amount of fun you just don't
like not being good right like you don't
like the learning curve that's what
you're objecting to and and the
realization that like life and progress
is this constant process of
bumping up into your limitations and the
things you don't know and if you like
that and you get better from that then
you keep growing and if you're the
person for whom
that struggle is immensely painful and
uncomfortable and it threatens your
identity and self-worth as an as a human
being you're [__] you're just totally
[__]
uh ego is the enemy let me get a little
extra going from here in 1953 Dwight D
Eisenhower return from his inaugural
parade and enter the White House for the
first time as president late in the
evening as he walked into the executive
Mansion his chief Usher handed
Eisenhower two letters marked
confidential and Secret
that had been sent to him earlier in the
day Eisenhower's reaction was Swift
never bring me a sealed envelope he said
firmly that's what I have staff for
how snobbish right had the office really
gone to his head already not at all
Eisenhower recognized the seemingly
insignificant event for what it was a
symptom of disorganized dysfunctional
organization not everything needed to
run through him
who was to say that the envelope was
even important
why hadn't anyone screened it as
President's first priority in office was
organizing the executive branch into a
smooth functioning and Order driven unit
just like his military units had been
not because he didn't want to work
himself but because everyone had a job
and he trusted and empowered them to do
it as is Chief of Staff later put it the
president does the most important things
I do the next most important things the
public image of Eisenhower is of a man
playing golf
in reality he was not someone who ever
slacked off but the leisure time he did
have was available because he ran a
tight ship he knew that urgent and
important were not symptoms he his job
was to set the priorities to think big
picture and then trust the people
beneath him to do the jobs they were
hired for
most of us are not the president or even
president of a company but in moving up
the latter in life the system and work
habits that got us where we are won't
necessarily keep us there
when we're aspiring or small time we can
be idiosyncratic we can compensate for
disorganization with hard work and a
little luck that's not going to cut it
in the majors in fact it'll sink you if
you can't grow up and organize we can
contrast Eisenhower's system in the
white house with the infamous car
company created by John DeLorean when he
walked away from GM to produce his brand
of futuristic cars a few decades removed
from the company's spectacular approach
implosion we can be forgiven for
thinking the man was just ahead of his
time in fact his rise in fall is as
Timeless a story as there is power
hungry narcissist undermines his own
vision and loses millions of dollars of
other people's money in the process
DeLorean was convinced that the culture
of order and discipline at GM had held
brilliant creatives like himself down
when he sat down when he set out to
found his company he deliberately did
everything differently flouting
conventional wisdom and business
practices the result was not the
freewheeling creative Sanctuary that
DeLorean naively envisioned it was
instead an overbearingly political
dysfunctional and even corrupt
organization that collapsed under its
own weight eventually resorting to
criminality and fraud and losses of some
250 million the DeLorean failed both as
a car and as a company because it was
mismanaged from top to bottom with an
emphasis on the mismanagement at the top
by the top that is DeLorean himself was
the problem compared to Eisenhower he
worked constantly with different results
with very different results as one
executive put it DeLorean had the
ability to recognize a good opportunity
but he didn't know how to make it happen
another executive described his
management style as chasing colored
balloons he was constantly distracted
and abandoning one project for another
he was a genius sadly that's rarely on
enough
though probably not on purpose DeLorean
created as a culture in which ego ran
free convinced that continued success
was simply his buy right he seemed to
bristle at Concepts like discipline
organization or strategic planning
employees were not given enough
Direction and then at the other times
overwhelmed with trivial instructions
DeLorean couldn't delegate except to
lackeys Who blind whose blind loyalty
was prized over competence or skill on
top of all this he was often late or
preoccupied Executives were allowed to
work on extracurricular activities on
the company dime encouraged specifically
to chase side projects that benefited
their boss at the expense of the company
as CEO DeLorean often bent the truth to
investors fellow officers and suppliers
and this habit was could was contagious
throughout the company
like many people driven by a demon
Deloreans decisions were motivated by
everything but what should what would
have been efficient manageable or
responsible
instead of improving or fixing GM system
it's as if he threw out order altogether
what ensued was chaos in which no one
followed the rules no one was
accountable and very little got done
the only reason it didn't collapse
immediately was that DeLorean was a
master of public relations a skill that
held the whole story together until the
first faulty cars came off the assembly
line not surprisingly the cars were
terrible they didn't work cost per unit
was massively over budget they hadn't
secured enough dealers they couldn't
deliver cars to the ones they had the
launch was a disaster DeLorean Motor
Company never recovered it turns out
that becoming a great leader is
difficult who knew
yeah classic and it's classic you know
when I just talked about discipline it
was freedom from a just personal
perspective but then also inside of an
organization if you have an
undisciplined organization you end up
with this where nothing can happen
nothing can get done no one knows what
direction we're going it's just total
chaos you think it'd be fun to get to do
whatever you want and it's the worst
thing you could it could possibly wish
on someone and and a good chunk of what
I was writing about there is obviously
what I just saw at American Apparel like
we we have this again this idea of the
leader doing everything being everywhere
being always accessible like I remember
when I first got there
said something about how you know he had
an open door policy any employee could
call him at any time he would answer and
I remember thinking like that's how it
should be done and then with time and I
saw it firsthand you go wait you've got
250 stores in 20 countries got 12 000
employees
you always have someone to wait with a
problem in some time zone and so he'd
get woken up from a dead sleep because
some store manager in Korea didn't think
they were getting enough overtime and
you know so he's he's
not able to not only take care of
himself as a human being but he has no
ability to see big picture he doesn't
realize he's making these massive
strategic mistakes because what he
thinks he's doing he's giving himself
credit for all these tactical
Corrections he's making all these
problems he saw and he doesn't realize
he's getting further and further off
course and so you end up I remember
Robert Greene told me this distinction
once between strategic heaven and
tactical hell and egotism is a good way
to get stuck or sucked into tactical
hell you think you're busy yeah and you
are the center of everything but you're
not getting anything done yeah and it's
very gratifying as well because you're
solving problems and people are praising
you that you got this done oh you got
the the new cash register order for that
store in South Korea great you did a
great job they're going to get delivered
tomorrow and you're you're hailed
because of it meanwhile you know three
quarters away you haven't ordered the
material that you need to get the job
done I remember I looked out of the
window one time at my office I stared
and he's directing traffic and the
parking lot and again this seems like
this seems like a humble like roll-up
shirt sleeves do anything leader and
there is a place sometimes for that
especially almost like it's a
Showmanship like watch me you know you
want the CEO of uber to sometimes drive
an Uber and get a sense of what it is
but Dove was doing it because he had
passed something on the way in and it
bothered him and instead of having
competent staff the way that an officer
would that goes you need to fix this
right now when I come back downstairs
this better have gone away he's doing it
himself and what he's doing is taking
his eye off the ball yeah and again he
likes the image and the image is cool
but the reality is if the CEO is not
thinking big picture no someone else can
direct traffic but no one can do what
you do and that that requires a certain
discipline and also requires
an acceptance of some things not being
the way that you want them to be that's
the hard thing yeah there's a certain
level I just was talking this with some
clients there's there is a level of risk
with decentralized command that the
traffic look I'm like hey Ryan that
traffic down there in the parking lot
was terrible you need to get that
squared away there's a chance that
you're going to do something that's not
quite what I would have done yeah
that's fine yes that's fine I often say
that the best operations that we would
go on
in Iraq I didn't have to say anything
you have to do anything I'm the overall
I got in charge but I don't have to say
anything because everyone knows what
they're doing and they just make things
happen which is the way it should be and
I never had to like if a guy did
something wrong I never had to correct
that individual the the guys on the team
would take care of it which is exactly
the way it should be
isn't it crazy that a guy like dove
can be so talented and
and
a genius to use your words
and yet just not see these things which
are so obvious
right now to just about anybody that
watches that Arc of Destruction unfold I
mean yeah you see this in sports all the
time this is the most talented person in
the world and yet that's not why they're
getting cut that's not what Kyrie Irving
is going from Team to team to team right
like it's obvious in two seconds what
that dude's problem is but you can't you
know you can't fix it or he's not
willing to fix it and so you know I
think sometimes like self-help or
personal development stuff gets like a
bad rap
but
the willingness to work on oneself to
like look at your problems in the mirror
to to focus on their that's important
work that not enough people do and and
it's not that egotistical people or
people like it's not that they don't
become successful Dove still lives in a
very large Mansion you know uh lots of
successful people were horrible they
were shitty leaders
um it's it's that it prevents them from
doing the things that they could have
done and that that's like the shame of
it you know what I mean like it
Steve Jobs gets fired by Apple
um deservedly so like his comeback story
is a result of his willingness to do
work on himself but like you don't
always get that second chance like you
think about yeah great people who
pissed off their publisher their record
label or people who couldn't play well
with others and
you know they end up depriving the world
and themselves of stuff they could have
done
um and it's really sad like again the
invisible graveyard of things that could
have been accomplished if people like
Shaq has talked about uh
the the number of rings that he and Kobe
could have won together right or you
look at the the Brooklyn Nets like that
was the greatest super team ever
assembled and they managed to be on the
court together like 19 times and again
they're all very rich all very
successful all clearly performing at an
elite level but there was some some
ceiling that they bumped into that they
could have broken through had they been
able to
Listen to You Know listen to the people
around them a huge part of that is
having the ability to detach
from yourself and take a look at what's
happening so when you say like self-help
would you say gets a bad rap or whatever
but part of what you're gonna do in
those situations is you're going to take
a step back and look at what you're
doing yeah which if you're in a business
and the business isn't going well and
what you do to try and fix it is Go
deeper into it and and close your
blinders even more you don't see the
mistakes that you're actually making
I've been saying a lot you the the
solution to a problem isn't inside the
problem you won't when you're in the
problem you don't see the solution you
have to get outside that problem and
when you're the problem you have to get
outside of yourself you have to take a
step back and look and say okay what am
I actually doing right now what mistakes
am I making and if your ego's out of
control this this will just never happen
it will just never happen you have to be
humble enough to say hey there's some
things that don't seem to be going very
well right now and I think I'm the
person that's in charge and this
probably indicates that I'm making some
mistakes what can I do better right now
it seems like so obvious and yet there's
countless stories and and this can
happen on a large scale like at American
Apparel or it can happen in a tiny scale
like when someone's in a relationship
with another human being and they don't
understand why the other person's
frustrated and it must be that other
person yeah without ever looking in the
mirror going maybe you act like an
[__] sometimes
I just um I saw this interview with Sean
Payton I'm a Saints fan so I'm sad that
he left but he he was asked like what's
he going to do about Russell Wilson who
had this terrible season huge contract
in Denver terrible season and he's like
what are you guys going to do and he's
like well we're going to break down what
happened last season we're going to see
the plays that went well
and then we're going to do more of those
plays and then we're gonna look at the
plays that didn't go well we're gonna
run fewer of those and you're like
that's so basic but that is first off
that's getting to the outside of a
problem right like instead of just like
forcing it like let's just do what we're
doing but we'll try harder right or
we'll hope we'll get luckier or we'll
blame you know this or that or the other
it's it's just like let's step back and
let's break down the film this is why
teams break down film and that's why in
the military you debrief you look at
what worked and what didn't work but
then also this is what coaches and
consultants and team members and
comrades and spouses this is what
they're like hey have you noticed this
pattern here like every time this
happens you do X is that and then how
does X go not well well then why don't
we try this instead you know and the
ability it's very hard to see yourself
from the outside by definition and so
you have to cultivate a process whether
it's journaling like that's what Marcus
Aurelius is doing in meditations or a
therapist that you talk to or a board of
advisors or a you know accountability
partner a coach or whatever that allows
you to go
yeah I'm getting in my own way here like
a lot how do I stop doing it and then
and this is what Dove didn't do you have
to listen to that advice that you have
to actually do that stuff which nobody
wants to do yeah the the idea of writing
things down because there's a this is
something I always tell people to do um
and it's something that you got told
when you were you know 16 years old and
hey do you want to go to a summer camp
or do you want to stay and you someone
goes well write down the list of pros
and cons and what you do is you you are
detaching from the problem even if it's
only for 18 inches away but now you're
looking at a piece of paper when you
have to write down your thoughts it
makes them more clear and it makes you
see oh yeah it looks like I should
definitely stay here and get a job
because I'm going to need money that's
going to be a better deal for me like
making those decisions and detaching
from them and writing them down that's
why even writing books for me as I would
write down debrief points for people I'd
write it down I'd see oh yeah I can see
this is a pattern here I can see how I
need to explain this better because
they're not getting it so writing things
down is such a powerful tool because it
de facto causes you to detach from the
problem yet there's a reason that almost
all successful and creative people
throughout history have had some kind of
journal in practice right where they
talk about how their day went or how
they want their day to go or the ideas
they're working on or the things they're
struggling with yeah that that 18 inches
that might be that might as well be ten
thousand feet beautiful it gives you so
much distance and it's also so much
better to vomit that out on the page
rather than on other people and once you
articulate once you write it down I mean
so many times I'm writing my journal I'm
like what you know that that is insane
that logic is not true at all or also
you've written this up like I'll notice
like I'm writing how tired I am very
regularly well that's a solvable problem
right and you you I obviously knew I was
tired but just the act of of just seeing
your thoughts is it that is the most
basic philosophical practice that there
is and that's what that's literally what
the Stokes were doing
how did uh ego as an enemy do really
good really good it was funny it was
sort of a nice so it comes out it should
have debuted at number one on the Wall
Street journalist and somebody at my
publisher made a mistake like they
entered it in the wrong category like
they put it in philosophy which there is
no list for instead of business which
we'd ask them for so what a debuted at
number one and uh so you know I opened
the thing expecting the number ones my
agent told me the sales and it's like
it's not only not number one it's not
there
and uh there's a chapter in the book
about this idea that the effort has to
be enough that like you control the
effort you don't control external
results which is a very Timeless stoic
idea it's also in the Bhagavad you had
to refer to your own book I was like
[__] you know [__] right because like I
knew I did a good job I knew I sold the
copies which ultimately is what matters
anyway not this arbitrary list of where
you rank against other people like I
know what the number is and uh also who
the [__] cares about the first week like
tell me is it still you know there's a
Drake lyric like tell me who you're
checking a decade from now like the book
is still selling right like that's what
matters it doesn't matter what you do in
the first week
um but but it again like what's so cool
about stoicism about philosophy is that
it it's for those problems it's where
you're like someone made a mistake it
cost me something but did it cost me
something do I actually care about this
thing what does it actually mean to me
and then how do I process these emotions
like I think people think stoicism is
like having no emotions the stoicism is
having the framework the understanding
of what really is important what you
really believe and it allows you to
process those emotions so instead of
sending off the angry email or you know
like putting my foot through the wall
I'm like
oh yeah this is a chance
this is a chance to practice what I was
talking about which I already knew and I
already have practiced but it's more
practice I had uh my book discipline
equals Freedom was coming out in 2017 in
October
mid-october of 2017 and so I had gotten
the pre-copies like like copies of it at
my house and I had a big box of them and
I had the big media tour thing all
scheduled
and my friend Seth died on uh September
30th 2017. and so
I you know canceled everything but but
then like I was distraught because my
friend died and I remember I had this
book that I had written and I have a
section in the book about death and I
literally had to walk over to my own
book and read that section
to to remind myself of how you get
through this and and again that's like
when we talk about writing stuff down
to
to distance yourself from it but also
like what you're saying you know you're
pissed that you didn't get on the list
the way you should have and like of
course you go back and like read this
section on that and it's it's the same
thing sometimes you've gotta you're you
gotta interrupt that emotional cycle
that's going on and say hey here's look
at this from a distance here's what's
going on and and that's why having books
like these are it's important to be able
to refer back to them
um
otherwise you can get caught in these
Loops that are not healthy yeah I think
first off I think writing is is like a
form of accountability publishing is a
form of accountability like I said this
and I sold it to people so if someone
catches me not doing it that's that's
not a good look so it forces you I think
you're like this is what I think but
then also when you're writing I mean
it's not it is you but it's also you
channeling something bigger and more
Timeless than you like you didn't invent
it you discovered it and now you're
sharing it or you uncovered it or
rediscovered it right and so like the
process of writing it and I think
almost
as I've really studied so one of the
interesting things as I've gone back and
read more of the obscure stoics like
there's a metaphor in meditations where
Marcus realist talks about like being a
wrestler I know he talks about being a
boxer a pancreationist like the the old
form of MMA and then I realized oh no
he's cribbing from an earlier stoic like
he didn't invent this that this exact
paragraph basically appears somewhere
else and he goes oh he was
reminding himself of the he was the the
act of writing it down paraphrasing it
putting it in his own language was a way
of kind of putting it in his own muscle
memory and so it writing to me is not
this generative thing it's more of this
like
repetitive
meditation do you know what I mean like
writing the daily stoic is its reps yes
it's reps it's reps on the squat rack
yeah
and you're going to get a little bit
stronger and they're going to get a
little bit more embedded and ingrained
in your head yeah it doesn't make it
easy to apply them but it makes it
easier to remember things
uh
next up
um The Daily stoic
366 meditations on wisdom perseverance
and the Art of Living
a little section of this
some of us are stressed others are
overworked perhaps you're struggling
with new responsibilities of Parenthood
or the chaos of a new venture or are you
already successful in grappling with the
duties of power or influence wrestling
with addiction deeply in love or moving
from one flawed relationship to another
are you approaching your golden years or
enjoying the spoils of Youth busy and
active or bored out of your mind
whatever it is
whatever you're going through there is
wisdom from the stoics that can help in
fact in many cases they have addressed
it explicitly in terms that feel
shockingly modern that's what we're
going to focus on in this book
fast forward a little bit organized
along the lines of the three disciplines
perception action and will and then
further divided into important themes
within those disciplines you'll find
that each month will stress a particular
trait and each day will offer a new way
to think or act the areas of great
interest to the stoics all make an
appearance here virtue morality emotion
self-awareness fortitude right action
problem solving acceptance mental
Clarity pragmatism unbiased thought and
Duty
the aim of this Hands-On approach to
philosophy is to help you live a better
life it is our hope that there is not a
word in this book that you can't that
can't or shouldn't to paraphrase Seneca
be turned into works
so this one
uh perception action and will talk me
through those things it's also the
structure of the obstacles away which is
basically like you control how you look
about how you control you look at a
problem right what you think and feel
about the problem then you control the
action that you take on the problem and
then you control the sort of willpower
determination endurance that you bring
to bear on the problem Marcus realizing
meditations he sort of sums them up
because objective judgment now at this
very moment unselfish action now at this
very moment and it says Willing
Acceptance Now at this very moment that
is all that you need and that is sort of
the encapsulation of stoicism the idea
that like what is it I'm not going to be
rattled by it I'm not going to
exaggerate I'm going to see it for what
it is I'm going to do what I got to do
and then I'm gonna I'm gonna persist
through it right I'm gonna like I'm
gonna endure it and survive it that that
is the sort of that is how you make the
obstacle is the way that is how you
apply stoicism in big situations and
small ones
I just uh did some Live Events and it's
interesting how
much of this one of the things I was
talking about is the the
the amount of control of your choice of
how you're going to view things right
what's your perception of these things
is going to be when something bad
happens when something good happens
how are you going to actually perceive
it and then what actions you're going to
take about it it's uh
right along right along the lines of
this which is which is which is pretty
strange
um and then this book right here so as
you're writing this
it's kind of everything that we just
talked about right this is like oh every
day you're going to remind yourself you
have a journal that goes along with
which I don't have a copy of it but
there's a journal that goes along with
where you can say oh here's what I did
today you've set it up in a way that
it's Evergreen there's no days so you
doesn't have to be Monday January 1st it
could be Thursday January 1st and you're
still good to go and you can just keep
growing through this book forever that's
been the crazy part I mean people are
eight years into it and so I'll sign
people's copies and it's like they'll be
like oh it's my favorite book and it's
like I can tell it's not and then you
meet someone you're like oh you put some
[__] miles on this thing and that's
like the coolest that's the coolest part
when they got four different or five
different colored highlighters that have
been used and different tags on them
different color tapes stay hanging out
because that's what my copy of
meditations look like looks like you
know it's all taped back together and
yeah almost every page almost every line
it's marked because at some point that
line spoke to me not the first time not
the 30th time but the hundredth time it
did you know and
the students talk about this they they
say that we never step in the same river
twice and what's cool about rereading
books is that
you're different it's the same but
you're different and so that's what it's
supposed to be and then I think the
other tricky thing is like when you when
you hear about a tradition or a way of
thinking like where do you start and I
think
when they suggested the daily spoke
which is not it wasn't my idea at all
actually my agent who did the
translation Steve is the one that that
suggested it it's like oh yeah start
with all of them it's like the greatest
it's the greatest hits album you know
it's these are the best ideas from The
Stokes it's like all my favorite quotes
and then I just Riff on them but I I
found that that can be hard like people
go Seneca marks Aurelius Epictetus which
dog should I start with and it's like I
need to know so much more about you
before I can you know before I can uh
tell you that and uh this is like kind
of a survey course of the stoics
and a daily reminder of what you're
doing uh and that stepping in the same
river is it because there's a the
continuation of that quote isn't it like
because they're it's not the same river
and it's not the same man yeah right
that's the continuation of it it's from
heraclitus yeah this Greek poet
um
I've found that like I'll I'll talk to a
company and I'll talk about let's say
the four laws of combat leadership and
two years later I'll go back and talk to
the same company
and some guy will come up like wow I
really like the new like the the new
spin that you've put on these things and
I'm like hey man I've been saying the
same thing for the past 15 years sure I
won't say that but I'll say hey
you're seeing it differently now you're
remember last time I was here you had a
team of four and now you got a team of
42. yeah and you were not publicly
traded company and now you're publicly
traded so you got it's totally different
it's a different River different man
yeah there's another line like when the
student is ready the teacher appears and
it's like it was all in the book but it
just it it wasn't unlocked for you you
didn't understand all that went into it
and so you or you understood it on a
surface level and now you understand
that you're being something totally
different and I that's that's to me what
like great Timeless amazing work is
um there's even movies you watch movies
or you read books and you're like
first time they were the hero now
they're the villain now they're the hero
again you know the Civil War is like
that for me the more you study the Civil
War you go
you start everyone has an arc you know
and it and that's what moral complexity
and reality is all about give me an
example from the Civil War well Grant is
fascinating uh
because he's
flawed brilliant flawed brilliant should
he become should he have been president
you know was he a good president bad
president is it impossible to tell
because the Lost Cause mythology you
know is is Robert E Lee this sort of
tragic figure or is he a monstrous
villain right or my my thing on the
Civil War is like you know you learn as
a kid you're like it was all about
slavery right then you study the Civil
War and you're like it was way more
complicated than just being about
slavery then you really studied the
Civil War and you're like it was a
hundred percent about slavery like and
you know what I mean it becomes I think
when you study things or you study
people it's very simple then it gets
complicated and then wisdom is the
ability for that complication to then
become a kind of Simplicity again you
know what I mean
um and so I mean that's why every time I
pick up a book about the Civil War I'm
like I do not need to read another book
about the Civil War I have so many
things I don't know about I should read
about something new and then I just get
something totally new out of it and I'm
like okay fine have you been to
battlefields
billion of them yeah what's your
favorite uh Gettysburg I mean you know
and I haven't been to a billion of them
but I've been to Gettysburg I think
seven times now so we do we do like a
battlefield tour at Gettysburg and it's
it's just awesome it's just awesome see
I'm a Vicksburg guy yeah I think
Vicksburg is more important we've talked
about going to Vicksburg Vicksburg as
well and yeah I mean you could certainly
argue that it's more important for sure
I mean this house should have should
have surrendered the day after Vicksburg
it was done yeah it's done
yeah it's such a it's such a crazy war
and one of the things that's interesting
about it is
um and I forget there's some there's
some sort of statistic you can get but
the the soldiers were really really
literate and they were really really
good writers yes and he you read what
they're writing about the Civil War and
they're like private soldiers on the
front line and they're super articulate
it's just awesome to read and you have
all these accounts of all these people
that wrote all these letter homes or or
kept these journals and you can get a
really close ground truth to what they
were thinking what they were feeling oh
it's so fascinating and then yeah you
read like Grant's Memoirs and you're
like this is like one of the greatest
books ever written and it's just this
dude like how did he write this I I like
Sherman the best but it's wild too the
Gettysburg Battlefield that just the
just the whole when I explain people
that I've been there before and I was
like hey here's how they set it up on
the one side of the battlefield you've
got General Lee on a horse
standing looking across the battlefield
from where his troops were arraigned and
on the other side of the battlefield
you've got General Mead on a horse and
he's looking where his from where his
troops were reigned like you can't it's
almost too good it's like the perfect
it's the perfect Memorial Battlefield
they're showing you how this thing went
down yeah you want you want to know I
love Vicksburg because Vicksburg is the
perfect obstacle is the way story so
they set Lincoln sends Grant because
Grant's like the only guy in the west
with momentum and they send Grant but he
also sends uh was it mclernon he's he
sends his replacement at the same time
his political replacement because
Grant's gonna fail you'll take over so
Grant goes Vicksburg now is like this
nothing City but it's the it's the only
stronghold left on the river it's the
most important city in America because
it controls the navigation in the most
important river in the country that
splits it in half so it's this Citadel
on the Bluffs there the Mississippian
so Grant's like Mall attack doesn't work
he's like okay we'll go above it doesn't
work uh he's like well we'll dig a canal
we'll just move the river doesn't work
he's trying everything right and then he
finally has this idea first off my other
favorite thing is Sherman gets there
Sherman technically outranks Grant and
uh he just says no no you're in charge
like surrenders superiority in this
moment so I'll do whatever you want and
and Sherman gets like the worst job he's
like running a faint he he gets like the
least sexy job in the whole thing but
anyways Grant and uh Porter and farrakut
they they run the gunboats and they they
skip Vicksburg altogether right there's
a thing that once you do you cannot undo
so they run the gunboats they make it
and uh they cross like 300 miles South
100 miles south something like that at
Hard Times Louisiana like the perfectly
named City he crosses and then Grant
goes now we're talking he's like boots
on the ground on the right side of the
enemy you know and then you so you think
okay he's obviously he's crossed the
river and now he's going to head up to
Vicksburg instead he says forget about
Vicksburg and he heads to Jackson and he
basically takes Jackson Burns It To The
Ground which is what was supplying the
Citadel in Vicksburg and then you know
months later now he's in this he's in
this thing for a good year now he heads
back towards Vicksburg and now suddenly
all the advantages of being a fortress
on a bluff on the Mississippi River are
a disadvant now they are trapped in said
said city right and he lays Siege
he doesn't give in uh you know he takes
like two months they finally surrendered
they surrender on the 4th of July
thinking that uh he'll be merciful which
of course he is not and then Vicksburg
does not celebrate the Fourth of July
until 1945 in protest in this but
basically all the lessons that Grant and
Sherman
use or learn there or how they win the
war Sherman cutting the supply lines
being on the right side of the river
taking the war to the enemy Sherman's
march is learned there at hard times and
for Grant he was like I've got more men
I've got more time I've got more money
he's like if I just don't quit we win
and so when Grant goes east and takes
over the army of the Potomac
it is from Vicksburg so not only is does
he take all the advantages of the enemy
and flip them on its head but also in
trying all these different things he
accident because it wasn't easy because
it didn't go his way the first time he
learns everything that he then uses
to win this award the battle of the
Wilderness the on the siege of Richmond
and Petersburg all that is from
Vicksburg yeah which by the way you can
never figure out if you're not humble
yes because you just stick with the same
plan interestingly we
my last deployment to Iraq we were in
the city of ramadi and we were working
very closely with the with the army with
the 11ad and they had a great Colonel
who became a general
and uh we were doing a big operation and
he so Vicksburg was the first joint what
we call in the military a joint
operation between the Army and the Navy
yeah because the Navy's in the rivers
people don't see that now yeah so so we
did this big operation and took down a
big chunk of the city and we called he
named the operation Vicksburg because it
was you know Army Navy working together
even though there's only 40 seals out
there that were working from the Navy
side but you know we were doing our best
to have an impact and he was
appreciative of it so he named it
Vicksburg I love that because it is this
remarkable story of collaboration and uh
egolessness in that Porter and Farragut
and Grant and Sherman all worked
together and my favorite moment I'm
actually just writing about this now is
I'm doing this series on the four
virtues and um friend Matt Justice which
isn't the legal justice it's like how do
you comport yourself as a person
well when Grant comes up with his plan
to run the gunboats and do all this
stuff Sherman's life is a terrible idea
this will not work do not do it and
grants okay take this I I hear you but
here's why I think I'm right in German's
like I think you're wrong it goes back
and he's like I think you're so wrong
I'm going to memorialize it in a letter
he's like I have to write he's so worked
up about what a terrible mistake they
think he thinks he's making he's like I
want to put it in writing so he puts in
writing sends it to Grant of course it
works out Sherman once Sherman's
overruled he plays along does everything
he's supposed to without a complaint and
then after its success you know Grant's
like giving Sherman all this credit the
reporters are there and uh Sherman walks
up and he's like it needs to be on the
record that I oppose this right at least
he's like I thought it was a bad idea
all the credit goes to this guy and then
when Grant's writing his memoirs Sherman
goes sends him another letter and he
says I am sure you have forgotten about
this and I know that you deleted the
like I know you ripped up the letter so
I'm enclosing another copy so the record
can you know he doesn't even want in
this moment he doesn't want credit yeah
undeservedly and he wants the record to
show like hey I didn't do it right and
you can you can see how easily a leader
can only focus on how the results went
that it worked out and not the fact that
um
they had like he won I think he not only
wanted to be honest but I think he was
also going hey this was an instance
where I got it super wrong and I want to
make sure that that's what stays with me
and what other future people learn is
that uh
you know I I didn't get it right I I'm
not a genius I don't have the Midas I
thought it was wrong I thought it was
wrong and then I was proven wrong I love
that story no I that's a great point I
talk about that with leaders all the
time anytime I'm wrong I'm super stoked
because it gets the opportunity to admit
to everyone that I'm wrong and be humble
and say look you had a better idea than
me let's use your idea I love being
wrong it's awesome I also always say
that I rarely have to admit that I'm
wrong and the reason I really have to
admit that I'm wrong is because I don't
run around saying I'm right about
something yes I don't sit there and say
well I think we should use this
marketing plan because I think I'm right
no I say well I'm not really sure that
could work how about this idea so if you
don't paint yourself into a corner by
screaming to everyone that you're right
or creating memorandums where you say I
want to go on record by saying that this
is wrong which is a weird tag to take I
guess back in the day you might have
been trying to
maybe trying to document that fact just
so if it does go wrong you can say hey
dude I pointed it out to you that's a
really weird thing at Gettysburg too
when you had Long Street and those are
documented too where he's saying listen
I've I've commanded squads and platoons
and companies and battalions and
brigades and in my estimation no army
ever assembled could take this position
and Lee's like cool we're doing it
anyways yeah and that's he probably
should have documented that a little bit
better than he did
yeah no it's it's so fascinating I I we
just did this with daily Stoke recently
where like they they had they put this
video together they had some one work on
it and I was like it's it's terrible
it's not gonna work you know I was like
here's all the reason I don't like it
and they were like no trust me on this
they put it out you know did like a
million views like our first day and
it's a good reminder too in Hollywood
there's this expression nobody knows
anything about what's going to work yeah
it's all guess and the second you start
to be right a couple times in a row
watch out yeah right
um like with trust me online uh the
publisher almost canceled the book over
the cover I knew it was the right cover
right here yeah yeah I think it's
amazing they didn't like it one thing
that's interesting my publisher told me
um he said look you know what we're all
talking about how this is when extreme
owners own extreme ownership is coming
out we don't know anything about like we
weren't you going into this Leif and I
were just Knuckleheads that were wrote a
book and
we're like well how do you think it's
going to do and and our publisher Mark
was like listen nobody knows nobody
knows nobody knows how good a book is
going to do he had some example of some
book that Oprah Winfrey was on the her
show at Oprah Winfrey's peak of her show
saying this is an Incredible Book buy
this book and like they sold 3 000
copies and that was that done so no only
the public knows yes that's why the
viral thing the creating viral thing
which is interesting because you talk
about creating viral things and you're
able to pull it off sometimes but even
the great Ryan holiday two weeks ago was
saying hey this video is stupid don't
put it out and it's a freaking viral
video with a million views well no one
so they didn't like the cover and I I I
stuck to my guns and it worked out and
then on a later book I was very
convinced that the cover should be a
certain way and the subtitle should be a
certain way and it didn't work it was it
didn't like fail but it just didn't it
didn't work and in the paperback we
fixed it all and so it's it's like I
could I guess go to my grave convinced I
was right and blame some other Factor
but at the end of the day you got to go
no you're not going to be right 100 like
statistically you're going to be wrong
like a lot and so I almost one of the
reasons I look forward to when it's
objectively and irrefutably irrefutable
that I was wrong I go okay this is this
is like eliminating one of this is if it
was never going this way then I am
clearly in the throes of ego because it
it's definitely happening I'm just not
seeing it so you want to seize on the
times where you're like yeah I think I
got this wrong I made the bad call
clearly it's not true because you don't
get that Clarity that often no no you
don't
so then we get into speaking of selling
The Perennial seller the art of making
and marketing work that lasts so this
was like a step back yeah a little bit
what brought this about uh I just got
lots of people who'd ask me for advice
on books because I'd worked on so many
and then the Publisher's like hey do you
want to do this book marketing book and
I was I was kicking it around and then I
was like I don't actually care about
marketing books I care about making
stuff that lasts like it's funny right
um
you're measured in the first week of
your sales we put something out like how
many how did you sell so if you sell
like 10 000 copies let's say you make
the best seller list but if you sell a
thousand copies a week for a year you
sold a lot more copies but you will not
appear on any bestselling list and so
people always measure themselves on the
wrong the wrong things right
um and it's funny the publishing
industry all of the money and
all of the successes on things that are
old right uh what they call perennial
titles or the backlist and yet all the
energy and all the focus and all the
media coverage is on what's coming out
like this Tuesday and so you know I'm
interested in the stuff they'll last
how do you make it how do you Market it
what do you learn from the stuff that
has
and then what so you write this book
well how does it do like does it look
like this is a niche market right
there's not too many people that are
like yo I'm writing a book I want to see
how I do this I mean it's it's more
about how you make anything like it's
like sort of lessons from sort of
Timeless work if I was doing it again
I'll I'd probably do it differently I
think I might do it differently
at some point like the idea is in it are
really good and it's all I mean it sold
well enough any author would be very
excited to have uh that number of sales
had you made the New York Times
bestseller list yet at this point
you know what's funny no no I'd sold I'd
sold well into the millions of copies
before I hit the New York Times list for
the first time which was a very surreal
strange experience the obstacle is the
way it came out it hit the the Wall
Street journalists and then has never
hit the New York Times lists and I
didn't hit the New York Times list for
the first time until I debuted at number
one with my like ninth book so these
things don't mean anything but that is
what you know people care about
you know how much money companies raised
right they care about like who's selling
but they don't care like is this still
going to be around is it profitable
right is it profitable and is it still
going to be around 10 years from now
yeah you know
two years from now 18 months from now
right like so everyone changes what's
popular now but they don't think about
is this likely to you know when I wrote
growth factor marketing I knew this is
only going to have a short you know
relatively short life but I think so
many people write things and they they
think it's gonna lie and then it's just
like what are you talking about this it
never had a shock you know it's never
had a shot and so I think when you when
you
if you're going to write a book if
you're making a YouTube video that goes
up right now can it can be of the moment
but if you're going to take the time to
do something like start a company or
book or whatever it's Gotta It's gotta
have the potential to have likes and
writing a book
again this is something we were talking
about before we hit record writing a
book is hard to do yes if you're writing
it yourself if you're going to pay
someone to write it cool whatever
you know you're weak but if if you're
gonna if you're gonna actually write the
book yourself it's gonna be it's hard to
do it takes time it's editing a book
is hard to do like the whole thing is
just hard to do it takes a whole bunch
of time and and what's really crazy is
like writing a book
you can you can write a you can write a
fantastic Incredible Book and it'll sell
you know 1400 copies and that's that
it's done and you can write like another
book that happens to get in some
people's heads and all of a sudden it
can sound like crazy you can write some
of your books that have like not done
very well according to the market out of
the gate and yet now they're selling
hundreds of thousands of copies over
time so it's a wild thing to get into
it's not a uh
it's not a very stable thing to get into
no like if you if you're out there
thinking well I'm gonna become an author
and sell a bunch of books it's that's a
rough that's a rough game to get into
well one of the funny things is since
the books have worked you know people go
oh Ryan Ryan's just writing let's docism
to make money
and I was like I couldn't think of a
worse thing to do to make money like
first off because I remember the
conversations with my publisher and I
was like I want to write about stosis
and they were like what's the least
amount of money we can offer this person
and it was a not large amount of money
and they told me later that they were
just hoping I would like get it out of
my system but then when something works
obviously it's it seems like obviously
that was your plan all along but but the
reality is books are a terrible way to
make money yes they are right and and
they take an incredible amount of time
and energy and they they torture you and
so like when I when I when I talk to
people and they go I think I'm writing
thinking about writing a book I go good
don't right like you
if you cannot do it don't do it right
like only write a book if you can't not
do it right right good advice like it
has to be something that you would be
happy with if it sold seven copies right
yeah I well for I had the same thing
happen when extreme ownership came out I
immediately was going to write a kids
book and I wish I could have recorded
the conversation with my with my editor
and this guy's a friend of mine he's a
great dude but you know he's like hey
like he's trying 15 different ways to
talk me out of doing this you know it's
just like crazy that that
you're just gonna get put in this
pigeonhole and then that's that and we
don't want to hear anything else from
you the other thing that this reminds me
of uh this is more advice from Tim
Ferriss when you're done writing a book
you're 50 there yes like when you're
done with the labor of writing a book
you now have 50 more to do that's just
as hard as the first 50 that you just
did when you thought you were done I've
described it to people it's you've
finished running a marathon and then you
know you come to the gate and you're
like
and you're staggering across the Finish
Line you you have this last burst of
adrenaline that got you through it I'm
done and they grab you and they pull you
through the shoot and you think they're
taking you to like the tent where you
can relax they put that metal blanket on
you or whatever
or the metal stand and they're actually
just taking you to the starting line of
the second Marathon that you have to
start right now and it's it's a less
fulfilling marathon it's a less in your
control and uh
it's also more embarrassing and awkward
at all the things that you you didn't
want to do to begin with but if you
don't do it no one else is going to do
it for you and what does it say about
like when people are like oh I don't I
don't do that Marketing sales stuff I'm
just like a writer or a creative I'm an
inventor you know whatever
I'm a purist it's like well what you're
saying is that your [__] sucks and that
you don't believe in it enough to want
to go on podcasts and talk about it or
that you don't know it well enough to
confidently sell it or Market it and so
yeah it it has to be a huge part of the
equation otherwise why did you do it
like why did you I'm not why did you do
it because like getting their thoughts
down on paper there's something valuable
in that but why did you slave over every
sentence and the packaging and like you
did all that because it's for people and
now now that the fear of them
potentially not liking it and the
potential audience being crickets now
you're trying to back out of it going
well that was never important to me I
don't care and so it's this tension of
like you have to be pure and do it for
only the right reasons and then once you
decide to put it out you have to become
marketer and a hustler and you have to
work just as creatively and committedly
to selling it to people and it's a long
[__] hard slot the obstacle is away
so millions of copies but at the first
week it sold
3 100 copies maybe you know
um and that was that was a that seemed
like a lot but in retrospect is you know
not even a fraction of a percent right
and so everything that succeeds comes to
dwarf what it did at the beginning
hopefully
and that's because you didn't quit on it
and you kept pounding the pavement doing
the work yeah so speaking of why did you
do it next you roll into uh conspiracy
Peter Thiel Hulk Hogan Gawker and the
anatomy of intrigue yeah so this is this
is out of left field book yeah wrong
subtitle then I forget what the new
subtitle is no no I'm saying like that
was a subtitle I was like this is the
subtitle and we fought I was like fought
so much about it and then now it's like
and it's like sex power and it
billionaires
uh Vendetta to crush a media Empire
something that's like actually sounds
compelling to read in retrospect like I
totally I thought and the cover that's
funny too because I bought into that
like I was like dude this it's like you
know pickles no like get a sandwich here
pickles barbecue sauce and you know
fried fish and you're like whoa what is
this I want to try it so when I see
Peter Thiel Hulk Hogan and Gawker I'm
like whoa what's going on here and I
kind of vaguely remembered the whole
story thing but well that's what I
thought and and you're probably like a
nerd like me so you're like intrigued
you know you like think it's gonna be a
spider but that's not what the market
thought at all
um it's my least selling book but the
one I am most proud of because it was
the hardest to do and it was the most
outside my comfort zone but basically I
happened to know Peter Thiel a little
bit and I knew Nick Deton who was the
creator of this company called Gawker
and these two basically wait you knew
them both yeah and I met them both
before
um I knew Nick from my American Apparel
days and I'd been to a party at Peter's
house many years so I knew them both and
then these two guys get blocked in this
10-year campaign to destroy each other
and uh
and somehow like basically the book
starts with um I at one one afternoon I
had uh like lunch at one of their house
houses and like dinner at the like I was
in both houses on the same day and did
they know that yeah and they were like
What's It Gonna you know and so I was
like I gotta tell because it's an insane
story there are people who don't know
basically in 2007 this Tech website
called Gawker outs Peter Thiel is gay
which he was but he was Private about it
and then he uh
decides to destroy them for this but
what they did was an illegal so he
spends 10 years plotting in secret
waiting for them to [__] up and then in
2011 or 12 they run a stolen sex tape of
Hulk Hogan Hulk Hogan having sex with
his best friend's wife
uh Bubba the Love Sponge was a Florida
DJ and that's the name of the other dude
it's just like weirder and weirder and
so they they run the Stone sex tape and
Peter Thiel hires a legal team to
secretly
Hulk Hogan never knows that Peter's a
part of it to secretly fund a hundred
million dollar lawsuit which they
ultimately win and bankrupt Gawker and
then uh Peter ends up bidding in the
auction like almost gets the assets of
the company in the end of it so this is
where he almost gets the assets he
destroys the company somebody else ends
up buying it like the judge wouldn't
sell it to him but it's almost a do you
know a spolio Optima so that in in in
Roman combat the ultimate victory for a
general to get it's only happened like
three times is uh you defeat the other
General on the field of battle hand to
hand and then you strip their armor from
them and so he's as close to that as you
could possibly get in like the business
world uh and so it's this insane story
which I use as a way of just talking
about strategy was your book a
post-mortem or were you in it as it was
happening this is all postmortem but I I
had like you know I'd read 20 000 pages
of legal documents and I interviewed all
the people including Hulk Hogan who
showed up he showed up wearing a t-shirt
a Hulk Hogan t-shirt which you know
makes sense yeah it was so it was an
insane story which I just really wanted
to tell and uh I think I did I think I
did a really good job I think it's
really interesting I know there's a way
I could have done it differently I would
have sold more copies but that wasn't
what the story that I wanted to tell how
could you have someone I could have made
Peter Thiel the villain and instead I
saw him as like the sort of fascinating
anti-hero of the story if that makes
sense yeah
um because like even if you don't agree
with what he did I was fascinated with
how he did it it's kind of cool right
yeah yeah I'm like there's something bad
even if it's bad it's still badass and
so I wanted to tell that story
which ended up being really I I was
fascinated by it Hulk I met him at the
UFC one time he's huge yeah well in his
he's a massive dude his life is very sad
his life was very sad and this moment
mm-hmm what's up with him right now give
us an update no I don't know what's up
with him now in the moment that this
happens you know his life is I mean his
life has fallen apart his wife has left
him his one of his kids is about to go
to jail
for I killed a guy in a car accident
um just like all the things that Fame
and success can do to a person it
happens to him
and then this most private moment is
leaked on the internet and then yeah he
wins this when ends up winning five
years later wins this insane lawsuit
that's been secretly funded
and uh I'm also just like you know Lego
um revenge is a dish best serve cold but
nobody can do it and nobody can wait you
know and except for Peter deal yeah the
uh the patience in the
machiavellian-ness of it is just I just
nerded out about it did he and he knew
that you were writing the book and it
was coming out yeah he he talked to me
so he let me like he gave me all the so
he even
he hired this kid and this kid
pretended to be fun this kid pretended
to have a wealthy benefactor who was
funding lawsuits but that was his
intermediary between Hogan's legal team
and teal so nobody knew teal
Teal's involvement was revealed like
three weeks after the verdict
so he pulled off complete in total
secrecy
that's freaking legit What did you
what did you uncover in the story that
like surprised even you
um what was what was some of the well I
mean just I was the first one to break
that this dude was there that there was
this this character intermediary the
deep throat if you will you know like
the the guy with the secret identity
that was that was pretty nuts
um
there's like this whole FBI sting that
happened that was pretty crazy
uh here's the funny so why does this all
happen why is so basically Bubba likes
to watch his wife get railed by other
dudes that's what he gets off of so he's
secretly filming it right he secretly
films Hulk Hogan having sex with his
wife which is weird you can say that but
but the reason it gets out is that
a rival DJ in Florida who wants Bubba's
spot on the radio
breaks into Bubba's office and rummages
through his desk and finds the tape and
he's the one that leaks the tape so this
whole thing this whole clash between
these insane personalities happens
because one weird Florida DJ wants to
humiliate another Florida DJ and it's
just the weirdest craziest story I can't
make this up no you couldn't like it's
unreal the Cohn Brothers couldn't come
up with this maybe they could but I
don't know yeah I mean it's just it like
it was the whole thing was you know
absurd it's the whole thing from start
to finish it's completely absurd so did
you get uh did your publisher buy into
this thing a little bit I mean they gave
me like much less than I normally would
get but oh okay fine go ahead and do it
yeah and then it's been in like movie
turnaround for like ever since I wrote
it but
documentary style real life style like
uh like um the director of The Hunger
Games optioned it and then the guy that
wrote uh
uh The Big Short he wrote he wrote a
script so it's like it's been you know
they've attached like multiple crazy
actors to each of the roles and then it
never happens what do you think's
holding it back I don't know I don't get
all I don't get how it works at all it's
exhaust I don't know there's just a lot
of meetings a lot of phone calls
sounds freaking wild it was it was
insane uh then you kind of get back to
your back to your roots on the next one
right
um Stillness is the key
you've commented on me reading this
thing right now so I'm gonna go hard on
this one sweet in our own lives we Face
a seemingly equal number of problems and
are pulled in countless directions by
competing priorities and beliefs
in the way of everything we hope to
accomplish personally and professionally
sit obstacles and enemies
Martin Luther King Jr observed that
there was a violent Civil War raging
within each and every person between our
good and bad impulses between our
Ambitions and our principles between
what can be and how hard it is to
actually get there
in those battles in that war
Stillness is the river and the railroad
Junction through which so much depends
it is the key to thinking clearly
to seeing the whole chessboard to making
tough decisions to managing our emotions
to identifying the right goals to
handling high pressure situations to
maintaining relationships to building
good habits to being productive to
physical Excellence to feeling fulfilled
to capturing moments of laughter and joy
Stillness is the key
to just about everything
to being a better parent a better artist
a better investor a better athlete a
better scientist a better human being
to unlocking all that we are capable of
in this life
that's about as hard as I can go on that
one no it's funny I forgot but I
actually tell the story of Vicksburg in
the introduction of that book Lincoln
calls all the generals in
everyone from the war department has
this big map of the United States you
know there's a million plans for how to
win the civil war the Anaconda Plan into
this and this all these different and
his
points in Vicksburg because Vicksburg is
the key he knew like in the earliest
days of the Civil War that was the city
that mattered
and the ability to sort of tune
everything out and lock in on what is
the Strategic objective that matters
more than anything else
is the main you know it's the main thing
like how do you quiet the noise internal
external
avoid the distractions avoid the short
term avoid the Tactical stuff and go to
like the essence of what matters
that's like the rare skill of all and
that's the one that leaders have to have
and you know athletes have to have like
the game online
you're shooting free throws everyone's
screaming at you can you do what you've
done a thousand times but now it
actually counts not getting in your own
head about it
you know that's that's everything
what other word could you use besides
Stillness
what I like about Stillness is it's one
of those words that's like you can't
exactly Define it but you know exactly
what it means
and that seems to be shared across all
the Traditions like the stoics have this
word apathya the epicureans have this
word ataraxia but basically it just
means like a freedom from disturbance
right like the even if you are moving
you are still right and in Zen Buddhism
they talk about
you know you have a cup of Muddy Water
you let it sit still it becomes clear so
the idea you know is is there and almost
all the spiritual and religious
traditions of some idea of peace and
tranquility and calmness
and if you can get there you know that's
where that's what unlocks whatever it is
that you need to do whether it's like
being present with your kids or at some
high stress high stakes scenario or your
life is on the line if you're everywhere
you're nowhere how do you get in the
moment that you're in to do what you
need to do that to me that's what's
still listening what are your protocols
for finding that
I mean on a day-to-day basis which is
weirdly both the easiest and the hardest
way to be to do it to me it's all about
routine and structure like what do you
do when do you get up what do you do
first when you do second what do you not
do so I'm a big I'm like a big routine
guy wake up at the same time
don't do the phone right my thing is I
don't do the phone for the first 30
minutes one hour I'm awake I try to take
my kids outside we usually go on a long
walk
if I'm by myself I'll work out by myself
but I do something physical usually do
journaling I don't do breakfast and then
I you know I take them to school or
whatever I have to like my get everyone
situated for the day thing
and then I then I write and then so by
like 10
or 11 like everything else for the rest
of the day is is bonus for me I don't
have anything I'm worried about any
regrets like I've if I crushed that
morning not only am I going to carry
that Stillness with me to whatever I
have to do for the rest of the day but
it's also kind of irrelevant because I
already won
that's cool
um I got a question no I got I think I
actually have the I have a an idea for
your next book oh yeah it's the other
path
that Ryan holiday took at at American
Apparel okay where like whatever you
know whatever was going on there you
just got caught up it's when you were
explaining that morning routine I'm like
this is amazing that you made it to this
situation where you're waking up at the
same time you're journaling you're
hanging out with your kids you're
working out you're carrying on with a
nice pleasant life in Texas I'm like
thinking back to when you were 19 years
old you're working in American Apparel
there's Mayhem going on there there's
models and and just drugs and Mayhem and
money and power and you're right at the
right at the seat of the emperor and
you're there to receive some of that
it's like this is amazing that you made
it to this spot where you didn't get
caught up in all that
I I write about this a little bit in the
conclu in the afterward of courageous
calling because yeah I've built in
retrospect I was clearly caught up in
something Colt is too strong of word but
you you get in situations that have an
energy and a a rhythm that you can't get
out of and that's that's what screws
with your moral compass like you get it
you can get competing in a game and you
can get so locked into the competition
of it or the winning of it that you
don't think about whether it's the right
game or not and I think that was a good
chunk of my 20s
and that that scene for sure I mean
there's moments where I remember I was I
remember
you know is asked to do something that I
didn't want to do and so I didn't do it
I said I wasn't going to do it but I I
should have spoken up more about it and
I was like well why didn't I and I was
like well I didn't want to get fired and
then it was like well first off I did
want to get fired I wanted to be a
writer so I'm like trying to not lose a
job that I do want to lose but also like
any job that you would get fired for
doing what is obviously the right thing
is not a job that you should want right
and so you know I think it was I look
back at that time and I was one very
young to still figuring out who I was
but I was also just so overwhelmed and
busy that I didn't I couldn't get to the
outside of it like we were talking about
I couldn't get to the outside of it and
go this is insane this is not healthy
this is also not what you want to do
with your life you've got to get out but
we always have our we have our reasons
we have our reasons and those reasons
what I've found is they don't age well
the reasons the reason that you didn't
do the brave or the right or the obvious
thing like it doesn't it doesn't age
well
is it a good assessment to say that you
were kind of like the it kid
I was the kid going places right you
were 20 years old were you getting
written about in magazines and stuff
like this yeah and I was also just doing
stuff that like no one in my family had
ever done I didn't even know you could
do you know I mean I'm just running
marketing for a publicly traded company
freaking crazy when I could basically
job for like a 53 year old seasoned like
person that been through the ringer and
you're freaking 20 years old yeah it was
it was insane it was totally insane
no not really that was sort of his thing
as he would give you the keys to the
kingdom but not really pay you I mean I
was definitely getting paid but I wasn't
you know I wasn't uh I wasn't making did
you buy a house did you buy a house in
L.A no I bought my first house in Austin
uh after I after I left and walked away
did you ever Kick-Ass apartment or
whatever yeah it was pretty cool I mean
it was a good life it was crazy and and
you were married at this time I was with
my we got married after but basically
yeah and then you know I sort of had
this moment I opened either it was the
enemy with it but basically like at one
point my wife is like [__] this I'm out
and I realized like I'd already written
two books I was like I have my dream
like all I wanted to do was be a writer
and I'm destroying myself I'm
compromising myself I'm compromising my
relationship
to do what to go to a staff meeting at a
company that is the former owner is
literally trying to destroy this is
insane
and uh this is insane you uh mentioned
moral compass yeah right where where did
you develop that where did that come
from was it from the stoics was it from
your mom and dad
like something like you put a normal 20
year old freaking kid yeah in this
position and the they're going off the
rails like it there's there's no turning
back like it's gonna get crazy and it's
gonna get real crazy and they're
probably not going to come back yeah you
could I should have spun off the planet
it was too much Temptation too much
access to dysfunctional environment I I
don't really know I mean I think
I I yes I think you credit the stoics
there that it stopped the slide at a
certain point I don't want to make it
sound like I was some choir boy or
something do you know what I mean like
because I was do I mean I write about
[__] that I did I shouldn't have done
but
um the stoic virtues are courage
discipline Justice and wisdom and I
think you know it's very easy to think
of stoicism as this productivity system
which I and this personal resiliency
system which is what I think I was most
excited about particularly when I was
young it's like this makes me better
this makes me faster this makes me
stronger but it's like it's not supposed
to make you a better sociopath you know
like the the justice is the most
important of the virtues because
what is the courage for right you know
what are you doing it for a courage in
pursuit of it a cause of the wrong cause
is is is empty in Hollow
now I know I forget which one of your
books do you say this but you basically
say that there's no Eureka moment yeah
but was there anything close to your
Eureka moment were you like you like
looked across the room and you saw
something and you're just like what am I
doing here there was there was some you
know it's funny I read this book while I
was there it's this book called The
Harder They Fall by this guy named Bud
schulberg who wrote on the waterfront
and um great screenwriter interesting
guy
and it's it's about this corrupt boxing
promoter who works with the mob he's
like a publicist and so I'm reading this
and you know has this section in there
he's like I deluded myself
he says that I could deal in filth and
not become the thing I touched and I I
was like [__] you know I wrote this down
and I wrote this like little essay to
myself like this is you I wrote this all
down in the book and so I remember that
as like a pivotal moment you know where
I where I
realized I was heading down the road and
I needed to make changes and whatever
and and that's why it's really important
when you hear people's stories that you
fact check them a little bit right
because it's never as clean and
immediate as you want it to be so I
remember that being
part of what you know leads to my
departure
so a couple years ago I was thinking
about this I told the story or something
and so I'm gonna go look when I bought
that book because I bought on Amazon I
pull up when I bought it I bought it in
2009 I read it in 2000 I left five years
later I stayed for five more years so
knowing something and then acting on it
right like knowing what you're meant to
do and acting on it you know it can take
you a long time you can know in your
heart what you're supposed to do or not
supposed to do but working up the
courage to do it is
especially when there's money on the
line or status on the line or just
inertia and the status quo online so it
took me a it took me a long time it took
me a long time that that you were
talking about the game too the game that
you're playing it seems like the
marketing game must have been fun too in
a fun kind of way like an immediate
gratification kind of way and like hey
we pulled this off kind of way and look
look what we did it seems like that
would be a a fun kind of thing to do as
well yeah to pull up a newspaper online
and see people talking about something
that you willed into reality that like
the sort of Puppet masterness of it it
it's very exciting it's very exciting
and then just just anything that you're
good at is exciting you just have to go
is this just because you're good at it
doesn't mean it's a good thing to spend
your life on
in fact it might not be a fingers
regular iPhone oh yeah you can get
wrapped up in that short-term
gratification I'm sure that's got to be
that's gotta feel good yeah and then
it's scary to walk away and do other
stuff but because I dropped out of
college to go like hey I am going to
walk away from this I was ready to quit
like I was like hey I quit basically and
they were like let's keep you on but I
was ready to quit to go write that first
book and so
that seemed that seemed equally crazy to
people at that time to at 24 I could
have left and gotten a job at any other
I could I probably could have gone got a
job at a startup that then would have
been worth billions of dollars right so
my options would have been like I had I
had a lot of marketing guide Uber yeah I
mean actually I remember Tim was like
hey I need you to talk to my friend
Travis he's starting this this startup
and he needs some words and it's like so
I had I had all those sort of
opportunities but I knew that wasn't
really what I wanted to do I'm glad you
did get involved in that because it
sounds like it it didn't work out yeah
uh next up was lives of the stoics The
Art of Living from Zeno to Zeno Xeno
Xeno to Marx Aurelius this is you go
into history mode yeah and so you're
again writing these books for you
for me writing books is just what's in
my head it comes out yeah it seems so
much easier I'm sorry that you have to
write these kind of books bro no it's
what I love but that's what you did yeah
and it's like well who who were they not
like what so the idea for the book is
not what did they say but who were they
and where do they live up to the ideas
and where did they fall short of the
ideas
Seneca being the most interesting why
was he the most interesting Seneca
writes the most beautifully he was he
was so famous as a playwright in in
Roman times there's a line from one of
his plays as graffiti in Pompeii so he's
like the most famous writer in Rome
and uh he ends up getting exercise
exiled under these false charges uh he
spends it in Corsica where Napoleon is
from which he portrays as this like
speaking of stoke you know Seneca writes
of course guys being this Barren
horrible Rock in the middle of the ocean
Napoleon born there writes about it as
this his place of his childhood which he
always wants to get back to but anyway
Seneca
is exiled is this horrible thing and
he's called back and it's called back by
the the mother of the future Emperor uh
this is Nero's mom she says you can come
back but you have to be the tutor and
advisor to my son which he does he's an
ordinary like teenage boy but it becomes
clear with time that Nero not all is
well with Nero and Nero becomes Emperor
and Seneca now is the right-hand man to
the most powerful person on Earth
and he has this moral quandary
of which a lot of people can relate to
myself included which is
yes this person is awful and evil but I
am preventing them from being as awful
and evil as they could be right where it
is uh are you the adult in the room or
are you complicit and so
he becomes enormously wealthy in working
foreign becomes the second richest man
in Rome
uh he just became complicit almost as
far as I'm concerned exactly exactly you
know this that's how they get you right
the gifts that you can't
give back and uh and he gets wrapped up
in it and you know he writes these Nero
tries to murder his own mom like several
times and Seneca is I think complicit in
the one of the worst Reigns so how do
you have this incredibly wise
decent man
a component of this horrendous regime I
mean I think he would justify it in all
the same ways that people have ever
Justified working for people like that
um you know look at what they would have
done to me look at what they would have
done to my family or you don't want to
think about what it would be like if I
wasn't there and so he's this immensely
complicated complex figure
that is both the philosopher but also
has these Ambitions this desire that
puts him in conflict with his own ideas
and ideals
and then
he does break with Nero and he's
ultimately implicated in a conspiracy
against Niro and his Nero sends his
goons to demand seneca's suicide and
Seneca has this sort of Socrates
christ-like moment you know you
he does it but then
he ever there's also there's something
that is inherently performative about it
that hasn't rung right to everyone since
that
he was he was both it was both brilliant
and brave and then also
some part of it about a Showmanship or
whatever exactly exactly so he's just
you know just endlessly fascinating
yeah
uh this book right here called about
face Colonel David hackworth the he's a
the one of the up Uprising stars in the
in the Army and he just can't take it
anymore and he's he feels like he's
complicit in this war that is being
fought in the wrong way and we're not
going to win it if we keep fighting it
this way and he ends up speaking out in
the press and they drop him out of the
army but this is something that I I talk
about a lot and it's that exact same
thing like you're here
are you the person like if he would have
stayed in he would have been the person
that could have said hey we need to
change the way we're fighting this now
I'm in charge of a brigade now I'm in
charge of a division and now I can help
10 000 soldiers do a better job and stay
safer but he just you know
nope I'm getting out I'm gonna tell
everyone what's going on and that's a a
tough decision to make because the
moment that you
leave all your power's gone
is there a chance that there's this huge
backlash and people get on board
um who was it it was the Marine that was
with uh Johnson and McNamara he writes
across the same thing yeah he he was
like the same way of like
like uh if I everyone says I should have
done more but if I would have resigned
my position I would have been in the
news for 24 hours and then that would be
that yeah it's it's immensely
complicated it's so easy to judge on the
outside but you don't know but I imagine
like General Mattis who's a hero of mine
who carries Mark surrealis with him
everywhere he goes I imagine he was
wrestling with the exact same things
that Seneca was wrestling with like put
politics aside like personality wise he
must have been he is as different from
the administration he served as you
could imagine and he has to ask in a
sort of who and what to my to do my
duties live what are my obligations
right and then who comes after me it's
so there's these are incredibly morally
complex questions yeah and yeah who
comes after me and once I'm gone I'm
gone and even like General Mattis as
immensely popular as he is I mean just
as a popular human figure General Mattis
is one of the most famous kind of modern
military humans
and when he left the administration like
there was a little bit of a buzz but
I I mean the decision have the big
impact that big of an impact and yet the
complexity of well I'm gonna I'm gonna
hold my fire till it makes a difference
that's how
that's how that's how they make you
complicit right like every one of him
it's always fault it's always
problematic when you compare Hitler But
like everyone knew Hitler was a problem
all of his generals uh thought he was
deranged and they all hoped someone else
would do something about it right and
and so nobody did right it's this sort
of call it the tragedy of the commons or
a collective no it's called a collective
action problem everyone needs to come
together and do it and the sacrifices
only matter if if enough people do it
but where does that leave you as the
individual yeah where and where does it
start yes if there's an you know the
active shooter if we all mob the active
shooter we'll get him yeah but he's
gonna get three of us and so
who's going to be the first three that's
rolling in and and look at American
Apparel I mean like I stuck around for
much longer than I should have and there
were there were moments that should have
been Red Line moments but if I would
have left I wouldn't have also been able
to after they fired him to make a lot of
changes to to you know I wouldn't have
been able to but is that something I
tell myself to let myself off the hook
you know am I not on the hook because I
was 23 and I shouldn't have been in the
position to begin with you know it's
it's complicated but I think you have to
be asking yourselves these questions and
like I think it was Admiral rickover's
he's quoting Confucius but he says like
the obligation of every individual is to
act like the fate of the world rests on
your shoulders which is like you have to
act as if your decision does matter like
you have to act on principle you can't
if everyone is a pragmatist then if
everyone is is only going well I'm only
going to do this if it's a I know it's a
hundred percent going to be effective if
I know it will make a difference
I mean
if everyone operated that way no change
would ever actually happen you need
progress depends on the irrational man
they say right like the person who says
I'm gonna do it I don't care about the
results it's the right thing to do I'm
going to say it I'm going to blow the
whistle blah blah like we cannot
function without those individuals
uh uh compare and contrast example I
bring up with this is
have you seen the the movie brand of
brothers or the series Band of Brothers
of course uh most people have seen this
because it's fantastic but dick winners
they're at the end of the war the war is
going to end and they they he gets
ordered by the colonel take a Recon
element across the river and so he goes
well why are we gonna do that he says
because I said so whatever so it takes a
Recon element across the river one guy
gets killed a couple guys get wounded
they come back
uh next night Colonel says take another
Recon on across the river and he's like
yes sir I don't think it's a good idea
there's nothing the war's gonna end blah
blah blah nope take a Recon across the
river Roger that sir and they go into
the basement of a building and they
drink wine and they don't go across the
river again and that's an example of
where like he could have stood up for
himself and he would have gotten fired
and they would put somebody else they
would take him across the river and put
guys at risk again that's just a good
counter example to the fact that when
you draw a line in the sand and you say
nope I I refuse to do this you're then
you don't have any control anymore and
you just got to be willing to accept
that a yes man is going to be put in
that position immediately and there'll
be no shelter and no uh buffer for the
troops yeah but there is a certain ego
in uh save your complex in the like I'm
I'm the one fishing the papers off the
desk I'm the one countermanding the bad
orders you know all would be lost
without me that's that's what bad
leaders exploit that sense of uh uh
that's what they need that that's what
sustains bad regimes and bad leadership
right so it's attention oh so you're
saying dick winners is like
perpetuating this bad leader being in
position because he doesn't stand up and
say you know what I refuse to do this
yeah or just the people that go hey I'm
I'm preventing them from crashing the
car constantly well the car keeps going
and eventually it does crash because
you're not actually the Savior and you
can't actually like inevitably
invariably they're they're gonna find
the thing that sinks them right
and are you just letting it go long
online it's I I don't know the answer
but well yeah I don't I don't think it's
one of those situations where you can
say here's the right answer
um because
you know you'd have to be able to run
both those courses in out infinitely to
find out where it actually leads and
even when people uh when people talk
about telling the truth right this is a
discussion I have in people say for
example oh your wife doesn't cook you
know my wife my wife cooks dry chicken
right this is the big joke and uh
well why don't you tell her why don't
you tell the truth isn't it wouldn't it
be better just to tell her the truth and
so I can tell you that that's not a
great option right if you tell your wife
she spends all day making you chicken
and getting her going to the store and
get buying everything and squaring it
away and cooking in she overcooks a
little bit so it's a little bit dry and
I can tell you that the right answer
is not it's not going to make things
better when you tell her the truth so
what am I saying a lie and what I've
come to discover is that actually no you
should tell the truth and you should
tell the truth to yourself and the truth
that you should tell yourself is that
you are very lucky to have this woman
that has made you this meal and you are
being a complaining whining
loser for not just being thankful that
you have chicken albeit a little bit dry
to eat for dinner say thank you because
that's what the truth is you should be
thankful yeah tell aim the weapon of
Truth at yourself sure same thing with
uh radical Candor right radical Candor
like oh uh you know Ryan you didn't get
this project done on time hey I don't
accept that you are are failing with
your timelines
what I should do is aim that radical
Candor myself which is hey have I given
Ryan the support that he needs have I
said explain to him why this timeline is
important
is he the right person for the job did I
place him in the job just because I
didn't take the effort so there's a you
if you aim the truth at yourself it's
going to be much it's going to be a much
more powerful tool and it actually will
be the best course of action yeah and so
so much I think radical Candor and
honesty or whatever this is really just
an excuse for being a dick and yes that
doesn't really help anyone or anything
no no uh that's why if you aim it at
yourself it it doesn't you won't be a
dick you'll be actually it'll come
across the way it should which is the
truth the truth about the situation is
you you're the problem whether it's true
or not is a separate question from
whether this is important or not whether
it's worth talking about or not is this
the hill you want to die on or not you
know and that discretion is super
important yeah I get a section in
leadership strategy and tactics called
don't care yeah and it's like well Ryan
wants to do it this way but I think we
should do this way I actually don't care
how we're doing it yeah well you you
said this no no that's fine I don't care
like believe me I care but I don't care
about the these little things that don't
matter well it does my wife said this to
me too it's like what matters being
right or the relationship or is this
more important than the relationship and
so often it's very easy to want to be
right or to want to voice your opinion
or whatever and and you don't realize
that it's these are peric victories yeah
and the truth is the truth is the
relationship is more important yeah so
why are you talking about something like
this because the real truth is the
relationship is more important yeah than
than who took out the garbage right so
get on with it
um
next one we're jumping into I wrote too
many books you wrote a lot of books I've
known I had to make a conscious decision
like okay what are we doing are we going
to do 14 different podcasts because I
don't know how many books you got but
you're giving me a run for the money
um actually no I think you got me beat I
don't know what's your number how many
books have you written I think it's 12
or 13. yeah I think there you go good
job uh speaking of General Mattis
this is from the book courage is calling
this is what 2020 courage is calling
what keeps you up at night General James
Mattis was once asked by a television
reporter before the question was quite
finished he he was already answering I
keep people awake at night
um it was an answer that captured the
philosophy by which this Warrior and
every Warrior before and since lives
their life the philosophy of offense of
initiative of intimidating the enemy
rather than being intimidated of
striking fear striking period rather
than being struck by it
this is why his troops were commanded to
set up and sleep in a v-shaped camp at
night a v pointed in the direction of
the enemy it's why he famously cashiered
an otherwise excellent offer officer in
the Gulf War for going too slow
to borrow a phrase from the British
General Sir Douglas Hague
loser in my opinion at Madison's core is
the trait that all great soldiers must
have a sincere desire to engage the
enemy
he expects nothing less from his troops
what are you going to wait for your
opponent to prepare are you going to
give them an advantage no way in the
civilian world we call this initiative
in sports we call it the will to win and
borrowing from the brutal World of War
we get this expression Killer Instinct
it is impossible to have a Killer
Instinct without courage one presupposes
the other and nobody achieves great
things in war business Sports life
without either of them the Spartans
never asked how many of the enemy there
were only where
because they were going to attack
anyways they weren't in it to win
um yeah in my note on General Hague I I
actually hate I loathe all the World War
One generals they're they're they're
horrible
um
he was even the American ones yeah some
of the Americans were okay I mean the
Marine Corps went in there and actually
were like hey hold on a second this is
freaking stupid but Hague
um butcher they called him
just terrible this Carnage and futility
and you know it's so disgusting to me
that he's like you're quoting here from
him as like a sincere desire to engage
the enemy and all he did was like send
two million British to their death uh
it's just awful no never never said hey
maybe this thing that we're doing maybe
the way we're doing is not working well
um well there's yes having an offensive
mindset and then running into a brick
wall or different things
but I think that's what that's what
makes Grant great right that's what
defines and tips the balance in the
Civil War as Grant realizes
oh yeah if we're on the defensive we're
going to lose
but we have more men more manpower more
money
the greatest industrial might in the
world we have to take the war of the
enemy we have to we have to win and he
didn't you know all my favorite Grand
stories are about that there's the we I
did a six-part series on the Civil War
called the Civil War Excursion we owe
six more my friend JD and I he's a he's
a freaking Civil War Maniac uh
just the Civil War in general
it's it's just an incredible thing to
contemplate
um
going back to the book here you say it's
been long held but there are two kinds
of Courage physical and moral physical
courage is a Knight riding into battle
it's a firefighter rushing into a
burning building it's an Explorer
setting out for the Arctic defying the
elements moral courage is a
whistleblower taking on powerful
interests
it's the truth teller who says what no
one else will say it's the entrepreneur
going into business for themselves
Against All Odds the martial courage of
the soldier and the mental courage of
the scientists but it doesn't take
philosopher to see these are actually
the same thing there aren't two kinds of
Kurds there's only one the kind where
you put your ass on the line in some
cases literally perhaps fatally in other
cases it's figuratively or financially
courage is risk it's sacrifice
commitment perseverance truth
determination when you do the thing
others cannot or will not do when you do
the thing that people think you
shouldn't or can't do otherwise it's not
courage you have to be braving something
or someone
courage is calling
um
what made this the next of the virtues
that you wanted to hit on a lot so I'm
doing this series this is still a poetry
Series so it's courage discipline
Justice and wisdom and I felt like
courage is the the most accessible and
the most exciting and the most inspiring
so I started I started there I know you
could you can't start with Justice uh I
knew discipline was the one I was most
excited the the discipline was the one
that I felt like I have the clearest
hook on I got a lot of texts when people
I guess it must have been when it
actually came out discipline is Destiny
I got all kinds of texts like yo what's
up with this some of them were like oh
this is cool some were like yo he's
stealing your stuff I got a few of those
which I thought was kind of funny well
uh you you picked a perfect title
although advised why did you call it
discipline equals freedom and not
discipline is freedom
um that's what I originally said
you know that's what I originally said I
just that's what I originally said and I
think it's because
I don't think they're the same thing
I think that one gives you the other so
this one will give you this not it is it
but it'll equal that so I guess that's
why you know we did the same thing in
extreme ownership so the four laws of
combat leadership are covered move
simple prioritize and execute and
decentralized command and they're not in
the same tense they don't quite fit
together sure grammatically and I think
our publisher was like you should change
simple to you know simplify and because
then it's an action that you take
covered Moves In Action that you take
prioritizing executes and actually as an
action that you take and I think they
actually had something for decentralized
command as well that would make it a not
a thing but an action
and Leif and I talked about it we kind
of came to the fact that like dude this
is what I wrote like this is the stuff
that I was saying so let's just stay
with what we wrote and you just kind of
have to deal with it so it's the same
thing with discipline equals Freedom
that's what I originally said when I was
trying to explain to these young seal
officers like this is what you need to
do if you have discipline it's going to
equal freedom for you and your physical
life your your your cognitive life your
your platoons like the more discipline
you have it's going to equal more
freedom that's what I originally said I
really struggled with the title of that
book because it's often rendered by the
ancient says Temperance like that's what
the name of the version but it's like
I'm obviously not calling it that nobody
knows what that means or if they do know
what it means they think of the
temperance movement which would which is
what banned alcohol in America so it's
like already super unpopular so it's
like I wasn't going to call it
Temperance and then one of the working
titles was only the disciplined are free
and then it became and then I really
didn't want to use discipline because I
didn't want to anywhere near what you
did because you're so perfectly talented
so it's going to be called
self-discipline is salvation and then I
found salvation for kind of has this
religious connotation but also it wasn't
it salvation wasn't the right word
um I don't know I just didn't like it
but like it went as far as like I saw
covers with that title like that's how
far we went down the thing self
self-discipline is salvation yeah that's
what because and and it is important
like you're talking about discipline
because discipline you mean
self-discipline you also mean discipline
like in the military there is discipline
and you enforce it on other people well
if you do that you're not a good leader
um but there is this but there is
discipline it is a thing right like
there is discipline in the ranks and and
they're imposed discipline this is how I
eventually had to break this up to
explain to people because you know you
do your best you can with your title and
you stick with Jocko sticks with
discipline equals freedom and so you get
some some leader out there that goes
cool I want freedom in my organization
I'm going to impose discipline on
everybody and then you have to go back
and say well we're not talking about
imposed discipline because if you're
imposing discipline on people they're
gonna reject it there's all these
problems that you're going to have and
it won't work out well but but I did so
I was like it's got to be
self-discipline people need to
understand so so that's where I was
going and then it just wasn't working
and then so there there's a Greek
expression character is fate right which
means like your character determines
what you're going to accomplish who
you're going to be that that your
character it's deterministic in the
sense like if you have bad character you
will eventually do bad things gosh
that's so important to remember and so
and what's so unfortunate sometimes that
takes like three decades I know but and
the problem is when people hear fate
they they don't
fate doesn't mean what it means to
people now so so sometimes that quote is
rendered as character is Destiny like
character determines who you're going to
be what you're going to do so it's like
that's that's what discipline is Right
discipline it's both uh it determines
whether you will be successful or not
but it's also there's something
inherently great about discipline so if
you go down fighting you might lose but
if you were just there is a form of
greatness even in the loss right like
and so so I ended up I was like you know
what [__] it this is definitely it's
it's the right title I have to stick
with it and uh yeah it was uh that was
the hardest of them to title yeah
well here's a little chunk of that show
me a man who isn't a Slave
Seneca demanded pointing out that even a
slave even slave owners were chained to
the responsibility of the institution of
slavery one is a slave to sex another to
money another to ambition all are slaves
to Hope or fear the first step he said
was to pull yourself out of the
ignorance of your dependency whatever
that happens to be then you need to get
clean get clean from your mistress from
your addiction to work from your lust
for power whatever in the modern era we
might be hooked on cigarettes or soda
likes on social media or watching cable
news it doesn't matter whether it's
socially acceptable or not what matters
is whether it's good for you
Eisenhower's habit was killing him as so
many of ours were too because you you in
earlier in the book you talk about
Eisenhower quitting smoking super
disciplined dude his whole life and yet
he gave himself an order he said he's
like I gave myself an order
um slowly imperceptibly
but even if they weren't even if they
were harmless why should we take orders
from our belly or our crotches or the
device that seems almost physically
connected to us at this point the body
can't be in charge neither can a habit
we must be the boss
he gave himself an order to quit smoking
I love it so much 40 years like two
packs a day
I had a guy came up to me oh so I I had
a guy write in on one of my early
podcasts was like he was a a nail biter
like bit his nails so if bleeding like
in meetings just like couldn't stop and
he asked me like what he should do or
whatever and I was like stop biting him
and then you know wrote back like I
stopped fighting like I'm good I'm
normal and then I had a guy came up to
me at the first muster this was really
cool a guy came up to me you know we're
hanging out and we're walking to dinner
actually he's come up to talk to me
and he says like I'm gonna tell you
something right now that I'm like
embarrassed to tell you and you're gonna
think it's super lame but I just want to
tell you anyway so you know what's going
on
I was addicted to video games as weird
as that might sound I would play 12 14
18 hours of video games a day that was
my entire life and it was absolutely
horrible and I heard you tell this guy
just to stop biting his nails and he
stopped yeah and I just stopped playing
video games after however many years and
I sold all my video game cartridges or
whatever and I sold my console and I
used that money to come here and come to
this event with you and I just want to
tell you thanks
just freaking give yourself an order man
sure yeah seneca's other line he says uh
no one is fit to rule who is not first
master of themselves
and so this idea I think that's what
Eisenhower was so powerful that
Eisenhower is that uh
he he he was literally the the most
powerful man in the I mean just imagine
to be the American president at the
beginning of the Cold War after you won
World War after you won yes after you
won like you not America you there will
never be a singularly as powerful person
again probably isn't it weird that
Churchill wasn't
right because Churchill gets knocked out
of office and also uh Eisenhower had
nuclear weapons I don't know if Britain
had them yet right so you're just and
there's a brief moment where the United
States is the only country in the world
with nuclear weapons so singularly one
individual effectively had the power to
destroy the Earth
and uh Eisenhower's mother had given him
uh that Bible verse like he that uh that
taketh the city is not as great as he
That Conquers his anger right and the
idea that that if your master of
yourself that stoic idea that's the
that's the greatest Empire The Stokes
would say the greatest Empire is
self-control self-command and you
realize there's way more people who have
been in charge of large armies or large
Empires or large companies or large
fortunes or followings
there are more of those people than
people who are truly
self-contained in self like you know
what I mean like the the discipline of
the monk may be stronger than the
discipline of you know the great
conqueror world leader
and you need that like who like the the
stoics said that you know
um I think every philosopher every King
should be a philosopher but he says at
the outset every philosopher must be a
kingly person and this idea that like
you need your leaders and you need your
thinkers to be in command of themselves
because if they're not what
qualifications do they have to tell
other people what to do or how to do it
is so bizarre that people get into these
positions when they don't have control
over themselves yeah how do you think
it's so freaking crazy when you go
characters how did you think it was
gonna go yeah you know of course it was
going to end that way
yeah
um I've
uh um one of the guys that I work with
now who was in the military with um JP
DaNell and he had like when I first met
him for the first time he had like a
broken hand right clearly because he
cracked somebody and I just you know I
said hey man like losing your temper is
a weakness and what was cool is the
reason I remember this because he told
me you know he's like you said that to
me and I was like oh damn because you
know he's grown up he sees his dad his
dad loses his temper this looks like a
superpower oh when you lose your temper
everyone listens to you everyone just
does what you said and they get in line
and then and that's the way that seems
like a good superpower that I kind of
want too so boom lose your temper it's a
superpower and that's JP and you know
he's now like 22 years old or something
and he's working with me for the first
time I'm like losing your temper as a
weakness never yeah never had that idea
never never had that idea and he's like
oh and he said it just like oh
you know again did that change him
overnight no did he get in trouble some
more yes do we have to keep him in check
a few times absolutely but it was like
that beginning of it you know he was
young I was like probably 12 something
years older than him but that idea that
discipline
emotional discipline physical discipline
like that is what allows you to be
good at making decisions good at
leadership good at moving through life
like it just all boils down to
discipline it's a weird Paradox of
masculinity that like crying or you know
being scared any one of these emotions
is weakness but then getting so angry
that you punch a wall or you break
something that's like strength but
they're this fundamentally the same
thing it's a baby yeah right I can't
handle what I'm feeling right now and in
fact there's probably actually something
at least the sort of uh you know crying
has some kind of emotional vulnerability
to it like it's almost I can I can
actually buy that there's something good
in that is do stuff the sadness down it
comes out you know and so this idea that
it's about suppression is not the way to
think about it either that's that's
missing what stoicism is it's like
I'm feeling something is this a good
feeling to act on or not you know why am
I feeling this how can I process this
feeling like that's what we're doing
right it's it's having the emotional
awareness to go this is triggering for
me I don't like this but it's not
appropriate for me to do X Y or Z that's
that's what stoicism is like it's the
maturity and the self-discipline and the
self-awareness to not be the victim of
those emotions like I think there's a
huge difference between being angry and
then doing something out of anger just
as like being sad it's totally fine or
being grief stricken is totally fine
five years later you still can't get out
of bed like you need to get some help
you know like that if you're so
depressed you don't want to be alive you
got to be you got to go you gotta talk
to someone about this yeah I went
through a whole string on one podcast a
long time ago that it may have caused a
little bit of backlash but basically we
were talking about I was talking about
emotions and what what is a baby a baby
can't control their emotions they get
mad they get sad like that's what
happens and so as you get older you
control your emotions more now there are
going to be times where you can't
control your emotions for instance
someone that you care about dies and now
you're getting hit with these waves of
emotions and that's what makes it so
scary to grown people because for the
past 32 years they've been able to
control their emotions and all of a
sudden their dad dies and they can't
control their emotions and it's hitting
them at these weird times and so they
feel like they can't they can't get
themselves together they feel like
there's something wrong with them and
what I am happy to be able to tell them
is that over time you will regain
control those and that will start to
dissipate and those waves of emotion
will become weaker over time and that's
not a bad thing it's actually a good
thing and you're processing it
never caught any crap about that but on
some other podcast I was like oh you
gotta stifle those emotions and there's
like a whole category of emotions that
you should freaking stifle you know when
you get pissed off at your wife because
she did take out the garbage or whatever
the thing is and you should stifle those
emotions that's what you need to do and
boy did I get a bunch of people saying
if you stifle all your emotions you're
gonna look like no there's a category of
emotions that you should stifle and
there's other emotions that are gonna
come out and that's perfectly fine and
in fact it's healthy yeah of course and
and yeah if you're if you're stuffing
them down you're pretending they don't
exist it's just like putting them on a
credit card they're gonna pop out at a
different time but but if you act on
every urge and impulse if you share
every thought that you have or you you
can't you allow yourself to be
overwhelmed by every Temptation or
opportunity you have you're gonna blow
up your life and you're gonna You're
Gonna Hurt other people you know so the
ability to go I am feeling this that's a
dumb feeling or an inappropriate feeling
or the Stokes say you know you got to
think about how you're going to feel the
morning after right like like
drinking is fine on the way down the
problem is the hangover and you have to
as you're contemplating an emotion or a
thought or an action you have to go
how's this going to age you know how's
this going to age and and the ability to
go oh yeah like
here's what I feel I'm right to feel
this way but if I type this all out in
an email and I hit send
it's going to be [__] awkward three
days from now enough to see that person
where they're gonna hold this against me
forever right or if I quit in a flirt
where does that leave me and so the
ability to yeah be in command of not
even command of your emotions but
command of your actions instead of your
emotions being in command of your
actions that's what we're talking about
yeah there's another piece that comes
into play when we're talking about truth
earlier and like telling the truth
another thing that you've got to look at
is where does the truth end up from a
strategic level or a tactical level so I
can tell you the truth in this email
that I'm about to send you because you
went behind my back on and did something
and I can send you it's the truth right
now
and it's going to make me feel good
tactically at this moment to tell you
this but now we don't have a
relationship anymore now I can't count
on you and I said the truth is
in a long-term view this doesn't matter
that's the truth the truth is I'm being
petty about something that's what the
truth is the truth when I aim it at you
is probably not going to work out well
for me and think of the truth over a
strategic timeline instead of a tactical
timeline people make all kinds of
emotional decisions on the Tactical
timeline and they're not going to work
out well in a strategic in a strategic
Outlook yeah Lincoln would write these
letters they're called as hot letters
and he'd be like this is everything
that's wrong with you McClellan you know
and then it would it would sit in the
desk and he would not mail it right and
that's really that's the emotional
self-control that we're talking about
he's right to feel everything and it's
good that he felt everything and it's
good that he didn't pretend that he
didn't that he didn't feel it because it
would have vomited all over the next
time you saw him but then he goes
is this what I want to send to my you
know to my general right now and where
is it going to leave us and do I have a
replacement yet and blah blah blah blah
and so the ability to just not take the
action on the emotion no one's asking
you to be a saint just just don't do
that stuff you know what I mean feel it
all just don't
try not to act on it good good lessons
uh and speaking of good lessons
eventually uh what is this 2022 you roll
into some kids books I did yeah um I
think this is the first book you sent me
is it it's not the copy I couldn't find
the actual copy that you sent me but
um yeah you sent me this book The Boy
Who would be king
and then you wrote another one called
the girl who would be free so the girl
who so the boy who would be king is
about Marcus Aurelius yes
um and it's cool it's really cool the
way that you wrote it it's basically a
lot of stoicism in these little events
and you know lessons being taught to him
along the way great
simple
read for kids to learn lessons
was this because you had kids like I did
yes I wrote it I wrote it in March of
2020 during the pandemic where I was
like I'm stuck here
how can I teach my kids about stoicism
and knowing that they have zero interest
in philosophy whatsoever and so Marcus
realist his story is so incredible you
have a boy selected to be the emperor of
Rome
and somehow it doesn't end in tragedy
and disaster
I just wanted to tell I wanted to tell
that in a sort of an all ages way and
and because I mean it's it's really
Marcus's life is a parable of leadership
like what does it mean to be selected
for greatness and to prove yourself
worthy of it that's that's what Marcus's
story is and then what about the girl
who would be free now is this
what's this story based on it I know in
the book she's a slave yes and becomes
free yeah is this an Epictetus it's
Epictetus version so I wanted to tell
epictetus's story
but I also I really dislike the idea
that stoicism is just for dudes so I
wanted to tell a female version of the
story and I'm like I bet you this is
dead an Epictetus isn't a boy's name
Epictetus just means acquired one so I
was like you know what I'll just tell
that I'll just tell I'll just render
Epictetus as a girl which is interesting
because musoni's Rufus whose epictetus's
teacher writes this essay you know right
around the turn of the millennium
about how philosophy should be taught
for boys and girls he says virtue
doesn't have a gender he's like you
don't care what sex your horse is or
your hunting dog you just care if they
can do the job right and he says that's
what what virtue is it's like the job of
a human being so I just I just decided
to tell Epictetus is a girl so people
who wanted to
teach stoicism to their growth like
seeing yourself in stuff is really
important and so I just didn't want to
do another male version and then some
people were really upset about it it's
controversial as if it was this sort of
gender ideology thing when really it's
just saying like uh
it doesn't matter if you're a boy or a
girl this is what it is means to be a
good person to be in command of oneself
which epictetus's story is so perfect
with like Marcus has been nerding out
about Marcus he's powerful and Rich and
has all this accent but Epictetus is
following the same philosophy and has
nothing
you know as shitty of a life as you can
imagine for a person that's what
Epictetus is born into a slave in the
Roman Empire he he he's owned by someone
in Nero's court and he basically looks
around one day and goes I'm Freer than
all of these people
because he's in command of himself and
they're not he watches
he watches a man suck up to Nero's
cobbler like to get access and he goes
my life is way better than that guy's
life and I think this is what ultimately
resonates with Stockdale and Stockdale
is introduced to Epictetus in college
he's walking the halls of Stanford the
Navy sends him to to Stanford and this
fighter pilot who's a professor there
goes have you ever read Epictetus
and he's like what the [__] are you
talking about and it changes his life
I have a good Epictetus story you want
this one yeah absolutely have you
interviewed uh Dave Carey
no he was uh he's like 80 now he's one
of the pows with Stockdale I flew off
the horoscany shot down a couple months
after and he told me he's sitting in his
cell and you know they would tap and tap
messages to each other
and the message is like Stockdale says
um
remember Epictetus is teachings
and he just goes what are you talking
about like the idea the idea that this
like 20 year old fighter pilot would be
familiar with like Stockdale had so
steeped himself in the still ex that
that's like if I was in the prison with
him they'd been like Jocko remember epic
who the hell are you talking about
exactly exactly and then he comes to
understanding means epictetuses in every
situation we have some Freedom of Choice
some things that are up to us and some
things that are not up to us and he was
saying focus on what part of this is up
to you right which is the essence of I
think what Stoke philosophy is and what
made Stockdale so great that's what the
Stockdale Paradox is yeah uh and I but I
just love the idea he's so that he's so
nerded out about it that he just assumed
everyone was familiar with with an
obscure slit philosopher's slave from
2000 years ago yeah that's one of the
one of the probably best lessons
that I've reinforced on myself with this
podcast was um you know you know Captain
Charlie Plum another guy that was in he
was in the Hanoi Hilton and that one of
the rules that he told me about
was
if you were in your with your cellmates
and your cellmate because they would
they would usually have a cellmate for
like three months maybe six months maybe
a year and then they'd get someone new
or they'd get rotated out and every time
a new cell mate would come in it was
like the newest
issue of a movie a new book and like
they just got to learn everything about
this person what their favorite food was
how they grew up they they would know
everything about each other's lives
but also you're living in a cell with
some other other human being and they
had a rule and the rule was if your
cellmate does something that annoys you
it's your fault
and to me that is the ultimate like
ownership yeah you and it's the it's
stoicism very clearly oh you know Ryan
is my cell mate he's above me in the
bunk and he's picking his toenails as
I'm trying to go to sleep
and it's annoying me that's my fault and
I need to readjust my thought pattern
and be okay and not allow his actions to
annoy me that's on me I wonder if that
came through Stockdale via Epictetus
because one of my favorite quotes from
hepatitis he says remember when you take
offense that you are complicit in being
offended there you go because they just
said it you chose to see it as mean or
directed at you or hurtful like at the
essence of stoicism is this idea that
like things are objective right apathy
says it's just our opinions about them
that are not and so like them picking
their toes it's not annoying my wife has
said this to me she goes I can't
frustrate you and that was very
frustrating to hear but but it's true
right like they're doing the thing and
then I am saying it is frustrating right
um it is like the frustration is is to
me yeah their thing is that because it's
not frustrating reading to me when I
pick my nails right like when I do it
it's not annoying yeah so because the
event is the event as we say I don't
like that it's gross what we make up
hurtful
Politically Incorrect whatever this is
all on us yeah yeah it is what it is
it is all on us in the end
we should take ownership of it one might
say it sounds like a really good idea
uh does this get us up to present time I
think so this is where we're at I'm
finishing Justice now I'm just working
on it this morning when I went to when's
it coming out 24 12 24.
how many how many hours a day do you
write
like this morning 30 minutes I just my
thing is like I make a positive
contribution every day
I do a thousand words a day and uh it
takes an hour okay and that's not every
day but that's when I'm when I'm working
a book it's that's what I'm doing and I
think I could go down to a half an hour
a day I've never thought of just
positive contribution that's a low bar I
like it though that low bar can really
make it easy to you know belly up to the
computer well Tim Ferriss told me once
he said just a couple crappy Pages a day
yeah and so if you make it because like
right now I'm actually not writing I'm
more editing and finalizing I'm
definitely I started a new chapter that
wasn't there before but I think a word
count can be hard because right now
actually it's more important that I'm
eliminating words than writing words
yeah yeah so it's just like did it did
it get better today
the thing that I found that really locks
me into this mode is that if you if
you're right if I read a thousand words
today tomorrow I can immediately I can
start writing immediately I don't have
to review anything I know exactly where
I left off if I wait literally one extra
day I have to go back and read
maybe you know the last thousand words I
wrote maybe the last 500 but I
definitely am going to have to reinvest
and re-engage my brain and redeploy into
this mode whereas if it's if it's from
my mind yesterday and I do the thing
that Hemingway did which was like stop
in the middle of this yeah stop in the
middle of a sense I won't quite do that
I'll finish the sentence but then I'll
write like where I'm going in a phrase
or three or four words you know you know
uh move towards the building take it
down and whatever whatever thing I'm
gonna write next I'll kind of just know
where I'm going so that way I can get
back into it really easily but yeah if
you take more than a day for me I'm just
I have to go back and re-engage the
whole freaking thing what I like to do
is so I write in the morning get it done
and then you know I'm working out later
or I'm hanging out going for a walk or
swimming or whatever ideas pop into my
head and I write those down and I don't
go back and work on them like I wait
until the next like so you want to be
excited about what you have to do for
the next like you want a to-do list for
tomorrow not
what should I do today yeah you know
what I mean like so I'm saving it right
so you're always like yeah ready to go
getting fired up for it exactly exactly
so uh so that gets us up to speed though
that's what we're waiting on that one in
the meantime you've got
ryanholiday.net is where people can find
you also dailystoic.com
both those things have Facebook Twitter
and the gram Instagram at Ryan holiday
and daily stoic at Daily stoic you also
have a YouTube channel that's out there
at Daily stoic as well so every day I do
like so the daily stoke the book is one
page a day but then I just do a free
email version every day I have for eight
years and then there's a podcast version
of it so I just it just kept going so I
do the writing practice every day I have
the email so that's totally free people
made a new YouTube every day
a couple a week but I don't do like the
video version okay but uh but you can
listen to the email or read the email
for free it's one dose of stoicism every
day oh you can listen to the email on
the pop that's what the podcast is yeah
check but you do longer podcasts I do
interviews too because you've
interviewed me before I know you came on
right in the middle of covet oh yeah
that's right we were getting after it
yeah
um so that's where people can find you
you got a freaking 84 books that they
can read you got books for kids books
for adults calendar books Journal books
you've got you've got some freaking
books which is outstanding
um and I think that gets us up to speed
does it we good yeah man thanks this is
crazy
Carrie sir you got any questions
um I do have one question so we we talk
a lot about open-mindedness versus
closed-mindedness and I was just trying
to figure out I I'm a fan of stoic
philosophy and I've followed your stuff
for a long time Ryan so I'm just curious
is there uh kind of a direct corollary
to that open mind versus closed mind
where open-minded you're practicing
humility you're being open to others
ideas close-minded you're kind of using
judgment and
shutting down as opposed to hearing
somebody else out you might like this
Marcus and meditations he writes um
remember things are not asking to be
judged by you and he says you always
have the power of having no opinion and
I think about that a lot I think
politically culturally with my kids like
so much of the conflict I had with my
parents growing up was them having
opinions about [__] that just didn't
matter and those conflicts pulled us
apart right because they didn't like my
hair or my music or whatever it's like
you don't need to have an opinion about
it it doesn't matter and you don't need
to have an opinion about
99.9 of the things that are happening in
the world particularly other people's
private choices in their private life
and I just see people they just make
themselves so miserable but it's it's
worse than that because they make other
people miserable too do you know what I
mean by having strong opinions about who
they should marry or how they should
live or how they should raise their own
kids
it's like people are not asking you for
advice on how to live their life and uh
it's called it's called self-discipline
for a reason to go back to where we're
starting like you they'd people did not
ask for your standards you can't hold
them accountable for not living up to
them you know like I heard someone say
uh don't yuck someone else's yum I think
about that a lot that's a pretty good
one you know people go that band sucks
okay you know like why why does it
bother me that they like that
but that's hard it's it's hard I'm I'm
trying to get as it
you become a writer because you like
having opinions about [__] and uh I'm
trying to have less opinions about [__]
yeah that that open-minded thing I mean
for me there's a constant Battle of your
mind trying to close because it's safer
it's easier I don't have to listen to
you my ego wants to be closed my ego
doesn't want to hear your opinion my ego
thinks my opinion is better than yours
so we're constantly closing our mind and
the goal is to constantly pry that thing
open be open to other people's ideas be
open to other people's perspectives and
it's going to make you a much more
it's going to make you it's just going
to give you a better understanding of
what's going on in the world and a lot
of that is driven through humility
obviously but keep that mind open uh
Ryan any closing thoughts no man I think
I said everything
I don't know if I've ever talked this
much in my life except for doing an
audiobook right on well that's what
we're doing I guess we're setting
records uh uh thanks for joining us man
thanks for getting down here
um thanks for sharing your Lessons
Learned of course and and thanks for
capturing these lessons for people and
getting them out there in a way that
they're digestible and accessible to
people that need them it will help them
he'll help them stay on the path of
discipline well it's a total honor for
me I've loved yourself for a long time
since I heard about it from Tim so this
is really cool for me right old man
appreciate it
and with that
Ryan holiday has left the building
Carrie you win a little Fanboy at the
end there after you know after we
stopping the mics you want the picture
of course man I'm a Ryan holiday fan
yeah yeah and just don't you know Stoke
philosophy in general but Ryan's he's
been pushing this stuff for a long time
and definitely popularized for sure this
in the modern day yeah yeah I picked up
uh life of the stoics uh when it first
came out in 22 I think
um and I've had Marcus Aurelius
meditations for a long time so yeah I
like I said when we were talking
I guess we can cover it I guess we can
cover
meditations but there's it's like a
muzzle to do an audiobook and just read
them because they're that self-evident I
mean they're awesome
so uh yeah we'll think we'll think about
that but the the agent lessons still
being applicable 100 today and it's it
was cool to
you were saying you hadn't really heard
much many people talk with Ryan about
like the whole marketing American
Apparel like that's a crazy story his
story is is awesome in that first book
he wrote uh trust me I'm I'm lying I've
never even heard of that book yeah so um
it is definitely an interesting book and
it's like he said you could you can read
it and be like whoa I can't believe
people would do this or you could be
like whoa I'm gonna do this you know if
you're a nefarious way of doing it so
definitely some stuff to or just be
aware aware of what's actually happening
out there you know where like oh this
this is a manufactured story that was
then leaked to get more press on and
then push you know particularly yeah so
let me give you an example of some of
the stuff in that book
um they got a book coming out they want
to make it they want press for the book
so they put up Billboards and vandalize
the Billboards themselves so it gets
reported that the Billboards were
vandalized
like like that's
yeah that's some chest not Checkers
marketing so those are the kind of
things that are in that book was very
very interesting
um so cool pretty cool to talk to him
and hear about all the stuff he's got
been going on and just like I said it's
it's pretty impressive that he went
through that time period of being the
kind of it kid
and money and all the other stuff that
was thrown into his face and he was able
to steer clear of that
sort of demonic downfall spiral that
people can get onto which a lot of
people get you go to Hollywood like
they're in LA with money and action and
go look at those advertisements you can
pull them up they have whole websites
that are dedicated to the the
advertisements for American Apparel you
can see it's a very
uh and like I said I didn't know about
it at the time because I was just so
detached from like fashion but when you
look at it you can see why why it went
Richter and why it was doing so well
because it's cool looking stuff you know
cool looking advertisements
um but very cool conversation glad to
have them on here so thanks once again
to Ryan for coming out uh what do we got
going on we got chocolate live by the
way so we we so look we sold out in Ann
Arbor Michigan we just got done done
with that in shy town we were sold out
there
what was your was your you were there
both shows what was your assessment
powerful
I'll say that yeah they were it it was
awesome it was awesome to be out there
we are going to be we got two more shows
we got one in Boston
the Boston when I looked at the chart
there's might be like
I don't there's not many seats left in
Boston if any I honestly I think Boston
sold out and Philly Philly so Boston
July 21st Philly's July 22nd there's
still some seats left in Philly it's a
it's a bigger uh venue but there's like
a handful of seats in Philly so if you
want to come uh and listen it's
I'm gonna meet you like if you want to
come and say hi I I will stay there
until we shake hands so bring your books
bring your books damn it I shouldn't
have said that there's all I signed a
[__] ton of books I'll sign your books
um just because look I I'm a normal
person you know I'm not I'm not in the
green room I'm not hiding I've got
freaking Nine security guards standing
in front of me uh to get me whisk me out
of there when it's over no I'm like
you're my friend and you want to come
hang out come and get it I'll be there
we'll hang out and I'll definitely meet
you shake hands you want me to sign your
book yep bring it let's do it so once
again next up is Boston July 21st Philly
July 22nd
come and get it man look forward to
seeing you there
and uh I will be
hyped up on a little something called
Jocko fuel when I'm there it's weird
because I love I love Go My Own energy
drink right I love it I love the taste
of it I like love the way that makes me
feel but I you know I have to put a
governor on myself right I can't drink
nine of those things in a day I would
but you can't right but at that I'll
drink like
in the matter of two hours I'll put down
three because I've just cleared hot you
know and
it's just awesome so Jocko fuel this the
the Jocko lives are fueled by Jocko fuel
100 so come and get some of that uh you
can get it at jacofuel.com you can get
the the protein powder this is another
thing of protein powder you know you're
traveling throw some some throw some of
that protein powder in your bag you're
good to go you don't have to eat that
crap in the airport you got the Mulk
with you get some of that the ready to
drink stuff is going Richter I don't
know if I haven't told you that but like
the the ready to drink stuff
it's just going the protein Mulk protein
shakes are going Richter wherever they
are people are consuming them at an
incredible rate 30 grams of protein just
freaking tasty as can be uh so check
that out
we got this stuff available at the
Vitamin Shoppe it's at Wawa look you can
get the drinks at Wawa you gotta look at
the bottom right corner because they're
trying to you know the big companies are
trying to do their thing to us they're
trying to push us out they see a threat
they know what's up
but where their Wawa vitamin shop GNC
the military commences commissaries uh a
fees we're in a fees now Hannaford Dash
stores wake foreign ShopRite HEB
everyone in Texas thank you Meyer I was
just up in Meyer country Michigan
everyone that's up there thank you
because you you all are getting in there
and clearing shelves in Texas and and
admired HEB and Meyer Harris Teeter
Lifetime Fitness we're in there where it
Shields
and by the way we're in little gyms and
little places also where we just went
heavy into Tennessee we're in all kinds
of stores and Tennis if you're in
Tennessee go into like your local
convenience store and see what's up
if you want to sell in your CrossFit gym
if you want to sell in your Jiu Jitsu
Studio email jfsales jockoffuel.com get
get it in there take care of your people
take care of your clients get them in
better shape that's what we're doing uh
that's shockofuel.com we got it going on
also we got origin USA you heard us
talking about
you're just talking about the apparel
thing you're just talking about uh other
companies making a t-shirt for 40 cents
and who is getting
exploited in order to do that someone is
getting exploited when that happens when
you can buy something when you can buy a
t-shirt for seven dollars
someone's getting exploited
and it's and it's and it's National
Security is being exploited as well and
the environment is being exploited it's
just destructive
so don't don't buy into go to
originusa.com and get yourself something
that's made in America that's what we're
doing t-shirts boots jeans
[Music]
rash guards we got the whole RTX line
which is Roll Train execute that's what
it is
you can do whatever you got to do
and we also have hunt gear so look we
got it going on and we're making all in
America we are taking care of our
workers we are taking care of National
Security we're taking care of a supply
chain we're taking care of the farmers
that grow this stuff
and we're taking care of you because
we're making you the best possible
product
originusa.com go get it that's what I'm
saying we also got jockostore.com
check where you can get your podcast
discipline equals Freedom gear yeah you
can get your uh stay on the path gear
yeah t-shirts trucker hats beanies
hoodies the way Echo Charles says this
is you can represent while you're on the
path 100 this is what was cool at the
lives people were represented on the
path it was freaking legit so that was
awesome to see everyone showing up
representing representing that shirt
Locker yeah that shirt Locker just it's
just awesome so thanks for the
sherlocker's a subscription t-shirt make
new t-shirts all the time like new
designs some are a little edgy a little
bit
risky a little bit layers there's layers
on all of them for sure one of the
questions at the Jocko live was about a
shirt Locker the uh everybody must get
stoned yep yep they asked about the
T-shirt so there's layers there layers
layers are always worthwhile uh Taco
store.com also subscribe to this podcast
also subscribe to the Jocko underground
also subscribe to the YouTube channel
for for Jocko podcast and origin USA and
Jocko fuel we got YouTube channels for
all those check those out subscribe to
them click subscribe
button
uh flips on canvas Dakota Meyers making
awesome stuff to hang on your wall books
we got a ton of books of freaking Ryan
holiday writing books like a boss dude
just just turning them out so check out
all his books he's got he's got I think
he said 13 of them pretty ridiculous but
they're all they're all freaking good to
go so check those out and then of course
I've written a bunch of books as well I
guess I need to get busy if I want to go
and freaking Trump old Ryan holiday
because I don't like getting beat
because my ego's in the way
but a bunch of books man reading as I as
we were talking about readings how you
learn you can learn from other people's
experiences you can refresh your memory
you can be detached you can do
assessments like all these things are
through reading so get yourself some
books we also have Echelon front it's
our leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership go to
ashlandfront.com for details uh we have
August 8th through the 10th I think we
got a couple spots open for the Little
Bighorn Battlefield review come and
check that out we got it we got it FTX
like back to back FTX has taken place in
Texas when's that September I think we
got in October then is the next muster
October 18th through the 20th listen we
sell out of everything so if you want to
come please
just go register we also have the
women's assembly that's September 14th
through 16th Jamie Cochran the CEO at
Echelon front and an incredible leader
in her own right she is running that
event for women
so you can check that as well we also
have the extreme ownership Academy
where all these little lessons
that give you the skills to make better
decisions to maneuver properly to build
good relationships all these things that
make up life itself
relationships decision making these are
things that make up life itself
and if you're good at them if you're
good at decision making if you're good
at building relationships if you're good
at discipline if you're good at these
things you will be good at life
so check out extreme ownership Academy
it's at extreme ownership.com we got
free courses on that on there that you
can take there's listen go take some of
those free courses if nothing else if
look if you're broke right now and you
can't afford to pay for some of the
courses that's fine go and take the free
courses the value in the free courses
you will benefit from immensely you'll
benefit with your family you'll benefit
with your business you'll benefit in
life
so get in there it's free get in there
get in there it's it's it's gold we're
giving away gold
if I could have had these lessons when I
was 23 years old or 27 years old or 32
years old my whole life would be better
I had to learn the hard way
now I want you to have them the easy way
go to extreme ownership.com
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families check
out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organization she helps so many
veterans
get into a better place in life through
the therapies that she offers and pays
for
so go to America's Mighty Warriors dot
org if you want to help out Mark Lee's
mom mama Lee
just an amazing woman and also don't
forget about Micah Fink
latest report is that he just fought off
uh two grizzly bears with a pocket knife
and a twig and he came out on top that's
Micah Fink he's got he's got Folks up in
the field right now he's taking veterans
into the field where they can get lost
and then get found incredible program
that he's running Heroes and
horses.org and if you want to connect
with us on the
interwebsryanholiday.net also Facebook
Twitter and the Graham at Ryan
holidaystoic.com Facebook Twitter
thegram and the YouTube channel at
dailystoic and of course Carrie is at
carriehealth Carrie under score helden
guess what he missed the boat he missed
the boat he had to throw that underscore
in there too slow too slow too slow
underscore have you tried to get that
you try to get that Carrie Helton yes
sir no nothing nothing
just just didn't response nothing no
response zero movement
is Carrie Helton
active no so it's just somebody just
sitting on it somebody parked it
somebody parked it
I got some connections let's see what's
up
let's go let's go and I am at Jocko
willink uh of course of course please
please please
just watch your back because the
algorithms sneak up on you put you in a
choke hold you'll wake up and you wasted
48 minutes of time so just be careful
that's the algorithm and of course
thanks to all our military folks on
watch around the globe right now
protecting us and our way of life
thank you for what you do every single
day and of course the same goes to our
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
and all you First Responders you
sacrifice to keep us safe here at home
and we thank you for that
and everyone else out there
from Marcus Aurelius Warrior
emperor
stoic
we should discipline ourselves in small
things and from these progress to things
of greater value
as we say on the podcast here
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things also from Marcus Aurelius
stop allowing your mind to be a slave to
be jerked about by selfish impulses what
does that mean do what you're supposed
to do
and finally from Epictetus
Freedom isn't secured by filling up on
your heart's desire
but by removing your heart's desire
or
as we like to say discipline equals
freedom
and that's what we've got until next
time this is Carrie and Jocko